thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best we
are in for a wild ride and hey have we
mentioned there's also a million dollars
at stake the total pot is a million
dollars no that it's not a typo the
prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain he knows exactly what's
about to happen oh my goodness yeah this
is over a heartbreaker for Mr svidler
Jana probably she pulls through once
again
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real oh gosh no time no
time oh
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
foreign
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
chess.com Global Championship today
marks the end of the round of 32 we have
one more match left to play in the round
of 32 and what a match it is going to be
with Timur a job of taking on Arjun
aragicei to determine which 16 players
will remain in the field I'm your host
Grandmaster Daniel naritzki and
alongside me today once again former
world champion Grandmaster Amman
Hamilton Amman an honor to be
commentating with you indeed Dan yeah
yeah for a former world champion I just
hope no one digs into the archive and
wants to bring up the logs we'll just
leave it they didn't know they didn't
know about the about the Canadian world
championship match uh in Toronto you
know that's why the cgc finals are in
Toronto it's actually in your honor
let's start by reviewing the bracket of
64. we've come a very long way in the
cgc we've had upsets we have had matches
go to Armageddon we've had blowouts
we've had a little bit of everything I'm
on and after the rajaba of eriggaisi
match we will have 16 players eight of
which are going to head to the largest
city in Canada
exactly yeah this is all about that
final ticket to Toronto and uh we have
one more match Dania that needs to be
decided here so really excited to get
into that today as we can and see what
this match actually means for your
racket as the winner we'll move on to
Face young
indeed there's one more bracket to
complete it is the group E bracket it
featured some incredible players Yana
pamushi has made his way through muradli
defeating svidler in a unbelievably
close match that came all the way to
Armageddon and as you're saying who
between Arjun aragaisi and Timur rajabov
is going to face yon to round out group
E it's gonna be an incredibly close one
and we're not just saying it I mean
Arjun and Timur rajaba if you take a
look at the match-up card Amman they've
both been writing incredible streaks of
late of course Eric icy Crossing 2700
furiously making his way up the ladder
he's something like 27 30 feet a right
now and Timur a job of doesn't even
really need an introduction but a third
place finish at the candidates in Madrid
uh really solidifies his case as someone
who can go a very long way in the cgc is
my assessment accurate
I believe so and we've also seen how
these two players have gotten here as
well right defeating huifon having no
small task and the same with Arjun
um a very convincing match victory for
both Arjun is uh you know he also had
that match against Magnus that he just
played
um he lost in rather convincing fashion
but he made it all the way to the finals
similar time control I think he's going
to be warmed up as well Dania
yeah I think he is and I think another
indicator that we are in for a barn
burner is the community prediction which
was essentially polarized 50 50 I think
it was 52 uh in favor of Timur ajaba
maybe because he's the more sort of
established old school name and 48 to
Arjun aragaisi I mean it doesn't get any
closer than that and I'm on there's
really you know obviously even with
matches that should be close on paper
we've seen blowouts right one player
could be in better form we've seen Arjun
aragaisy delivering you know total
blowouts to some of the strongest
Grandmasters in the world but I think
this is a clear indicator that it is
impossible to predict the course that
this match is going to take which is
even more reason to cancel whatever
plans you have in the next couple of
hours make yourself a nice cup of coffee
and watch the action unfold that's right
no this will be a lot of fun
um I think that you pretty much called
it is right down the middle
um obviously a lot of people correctly
predicted this bracket but then from
there
it's 50 50. you don't know what's going
to happen it's the last match to
determine our final appearance for the
round of 16. so a lot is on the line
here that's why we only have one match
today Dania because this this honestly
determines everything going forward
yeah we'll be able to focus on each game
well
if you don't know the format of the cgc
then where have you been but for those
who might be late to the party a quick
recap of the logistics the cgc has a 15
minute plus two second time control each
match consists of four games and if the
match ends in a 2-2 tie then it goes to
an Armageddon we've had a lot of
Armageddon in the cgc most recently Jana
pamushi pulling out a flag over Peter
swidler in the Armageddon and I just
love the format I love the fact that we
go straight into the Armageddon no Blitz
playoff you know you don't have five
minutes and then three minutes you're
going straight into uh the decisive game
that really caters to some of the most
exciting match chests Amman that we've
seen ever
yeah I think the cgc has done a great
job at just making things exciting right
we have that four game match and then
like you said as soon as it's tied
there's no you know beating around the
bush they get right into it and all of a
sudden somebody's knocked out in the
very next game so guaranteed excitement
I think there's a good chance that this
match does indeed go to Armageddon but
you've got two set I mean such
interesting Styles between rajabov and
Eric I see that younger player he's he's
got that fire in him he plays really
exciting chess rajabov he sort of
cemented himself right at the top and I
always feel Dania that just doesn't
quite get enough credit for how Rock
Solid and talented he is to stay at the
you know Elite level of chess
and he's a shape-shifter you're exactly
right I mean tomorrow job grew up
playing the French he used the French to
beat Gary Kasparov I think aged 16 in
2003 he played the king's Indian against
one D4 exclusively and he has really
changed his style uh to make it that
much more solid you know he started
playing the Queen's gamma Decline and
you know with the white pieces he
solidified his opening repertoire as
well and that is what you need to
succeed at the top level nowadays but at
his core Timur rajabov is still the
rajaba who played the French against
Kasparov who loves explosive positions
and I think our generic icy is exactly
the same way he's capable of playing
very positionally he has a very measured
style but you know he loves
confrontation he loves displaying sharp
opening preparation and I'm really
hoping for a king's Indian or a French
or one of those gritty openings in this
match
absolutely and you know if people need a
reminder it's insanely difficult to
qualify for the candidates some people
spend their entire careers at 27.50 plus
and never make it there and not only did
Java make it there they came third
overall Dania so I mean we're talking
about someone who's experienced a lot of
recent success at the absolute highest
level and now you know going uh right
back down to the bottom of the age
category there you've got our generic
icy 19 years old who's looking to once
again I mean this would be a huge step
in his journey as a young uh upcoming
player to take over Jabba if you're in
the cgc
yeah and and Arjun you know maybe I'm
you know inventing stuff that isn't
valid but I feel like there is a new
style I don't know what to call it yet a
new Young player style that has been
permeating uh young players you know
aged under 20 I think all he has a
farugia belongs to this category our
generic I see his compatriot uh gukesh
it's a style that is incredibly
well-rounded more well-rounded than we
have seen young players play uh at any
other point in chess history young
players used to be associated with you
know super tactical style uh positional
heirs even young Grandmasters 10 15
years ago would often commit serious
positional errors and the older players
would drag them into you know long
boring end games or boring positional
struggles I'm on you can't do that
anymore because these young players are
just as good if not better at end games
than the older generation just look at
all your as a farouza who you know wins
equal and games on the regular against
players twice as old as him yeah that
you know that used to be the the
fallback plan it's like okay yeah let me
steer away from the Tactical skirmishes
and uh you know I'm gonna use my
experience and technique in the end game
but I mean as you pointed out that's no
longer a guarantee so should be a really
exciting match because I'm wondering
where we're going to find the
differences between those two players
sometimes Dania it is the closest
matchups on paper that are the biggest
blowouts when the match actually happens
so really excited to get into this one
we just saw the players on cam there so
we have both of them with us and uh
looking forward to this match
yeah me too and and I'm looking forward
to the openings uh I think a lot of the
match the nature of the match is going
to be decided uh by the open
we're going to see I mean are we going
to see a king's Indian you know uh
French or are we gonna see uh the
openings that Timur has been playing
recently one D4 with white Queen's gamma
declined and one E5 with black were that
question is about to get answered
because the games are underway ladies
and gentlemen seat belts fastened and
mandatory and in game one we do indeed
have a queen's gamma declined and a
ragozan by Arjun aragaisi
this is a really interesting opening
um first of all of course the players
are so closely seated but rajabov with
that second seed is going to start with
the white pieces
um as the the higher seeded player
um the red goes in his is uh I guess
slightly more ambitious of a of an
opening to to start things off but it's
just got such a solid reputation for
black and as I get that word solid out
of my mouth Dania I I see the move G4 on
the board for what Tim Moore waiting for
you to say that already a couple of
surprises not just G4 but if we rewind
just two moves this move A3 uh that came
as a slight surprise to me I think
Bishop D3 or Rook C1 all right here's
more standard fair but G4 part of a
recent Trend among where people seem to
be playing G4 and H4 and virtually every
position and I think tomorrow Jabba's
intentions are completely clear I want
to give Checkmate to the black king
exactly like there was a time in chess
Daniel where people did this way before
these Grand Masters but the difference
was I don't think they did it with as
much actual foundation and you know
computer backing as we have now
um so it is an exciting new way that
people are playing they're getting it to
work they're finding these G4S each
fours in every position A3 brought the
b-pawn closer to the center don't take
your eyes off the b-pawn it's now
sitting on D4
yeah it has come a very very long way
indeed and the sort of generally
approved prescription for fighting early
flank play Amman is striking in the
center you want to open up the center
then you want to strike in the center uh
because the logic is that if you're
playing you're making flank moves you're
pushing pawns on the sides of the board
and we see team we're on Java playing G5
anyway your Center is going to be weak
this is crazy so H takes G5 I think he
wants Rook G1 and he's going to win the
pawn back this is still preparation
which is absolutely nuts yeah it must be
preparation
um and the way that he's played it so
calm cool collected and the fact that
the engine isn't you know screaming in
either direction either direction I
think also means it's probably pretty
dangerous prep
um each takes Rook G1 Knight takes G5
and remember that Queen on D1 is gonna
slide out to the H5 Square starts to
look really frightening
yeah Rook q1 is already on the board and
at this point our generic icy has a
choice I mean the most tempting move I
think for most people if we can pull up
an analysis board would bb7v5 to defend
the C4 upon presumably Timur is going to
take on G5 with the Knight and as you
pointed out Queen H5 is already a
serious force to be reckoned with if
black plays a nonchalant move like
Bishop B7 you can see the Evo bar
creeping up Queen H5 and at first you
might say oh no problem I just go Queen
H6 all of a sudden white trades Queens
Knight takes C6 and the rook and f8 is
lost and if black plays Queen G6 then
it's still terrible I'm on take Stakes
Knight takes C6 and Black's position is
completely in shambles that's right it's
so easy for it to go wrong oh that's a
nasty one look at that line it takes B7
and boom Bishop G2 skewering the Rooks I
honestly don't think I've seen the Rooks
get skewered like that ever like
that's a very weird one you can take on
B7 trapping the other Rook on A8 oh man
yeah so I mean it's very it's very easy
to understand prep I always find Dania
like you know there's different styles
of preparation this one is the scariest
to me because if you you know sort of in
your minds flip the board and observe
this from Black's point of view
this doesn't look like something where
you're like okay what's the next engine
move that's coming you're just looking
at it and you're thinking okay Knight
takes pawn queen H5 and I made it and
that's tough to deal with when your
opponent's position looks so darn easy
to play
no that's the most tilting sensation you
know you watch your clock ticking down
your opponent is still at 15 minutes
there's Knight B8 to D7 by Arjun
and I'm very curious what he plans
against Knight takes G5 we should also
not forget that Timur after Knight takes
G5 and Bishop takes C4 uh material will
be equal so that's right is kind of
getting this sort of attack potentially
for free which is sort of a
disconcerting thought he takes on C4
first
I guess there's no hurry to take on G5
that Pawn's not going anywhere
yeah the thing is at any point I think
rajabov can just switch back and play
normal game meaning if the Queens get
traded
I think White's still fine right as long
as he balances out the material this
could just be a regular game so that's
the interesting thing about prep like
this is that you're overreacting
thinking how you're going to stop it as
black and then it's like wait a minute
congrats you stopped it but we're still
playing a chess game out here and white
doesn't have to full commit to this
attack he hasn't ruined everything in
his position yeah nor does white have to
promise that I'm going to Checkmate you
in the next five moves or I'm going to
resign right uh the attack you know I
think White's actually going to switch
to a sort of long-term attacking
strategy uh maybe Knight takes G5 drop
the bishop back to D3 uh maybe bring the
queen into F3 White's King uh isn't the
safest I mean white has pushed the Jeep
on up to G5 but uh this Pawn chain I'm
on F2 E3 D4 is still an incredibly solid
one and white has certain positional
pluses such as a better Bishop for the
time being at least
yeah and the king is relatively safe
because I mean check out the biggest
threat to White's King Black's Queen is
sitting on H6 you know a defensive piece
at best so the king can actually
probably just sit on E1 or maybe play
King E2 at the right moment later and
the Rooks will connect on the first rank
so I completely agree I don't think you
need to rush and the other thing is that
Bishop on C8 might have a hard time
getting developed
um you know if you put something like
night to Knight takes G5 on the board
and you know Pawn to B6 if we get an
analysis for it something like Queen F3
exactly and
um you know we're kind of hitting the
Rook here and the bishop wants to go on
B7 might want to go on A6 but it can't
move anywhere so plaque's a little bit
slow getting developed here
yeah well B7 is controlled uh White is
accumulating pieces on the king side
and it's already trouble you're gonna
have to go Rook B8 and then as you were
pointing out yeah Queen F4 Bishop T3
this just looks ugly for black I mean
even if you do put your Bishop on B7 uh
congratulations at this point there are
already tactics with Knight takes
uh so so I
I don't like flash position I think this
is phenomenal prep by team over a job of
it's way too early to say Obviously
whether
uh this is successful and see more
taking really his first think of the
game after Queen H6 my guess Iman is
that he is trying to evaluate Queen
takes H2 which has to be taken seriously
yeah it's uh
it's really annoying when your queen is
still in D1 in these situations because
the move that you would like to make is
long Castle sometimes just to connect
the Rooks and that's how you defend the
Rook on G1 but having to defend with a
piece I mean for example Knight back to
F3 is a not a move you want to make yeah
it deals with the problem but okay the
queen can go back to H6 and what have
you really done so you'd like to do it
in a different way maybe Queen and G4 as
as you're highlighting discards The Rook
although here there's Knight F6 exactly
Black's Pieces come into action really
quickly all of a sudden you know the
only way to defend your Rook might be
trading queens and remember Queen takes
H2 Dania did pick up that pawn so if you
trade queens now you're going to be down
upon
yeah and that is the worst case scenario
going into an end game you're down a
pawn and for this reason if we go back
to the live position Rook takes G5 is on
the board I think a big part of it was
that Timur didn't want to give up the H2
pawn and this is uh this kind of
epitomizes the shift in your job off
style I think the rajaba of of uh 2005
would have taken on G5 with a knight in
a couple of seconds right you know the
35 year old team were a job of he plays
a little bit more conservatively and uh
you know that's a style that not a lot
of people like to play against maybe
Arjun was excited at the opportunity to
mix things up uh make a daring move and
Timur says no no no that ain't gonna
happen but Amman Rook takes u5 is a very
serious downside this Rook is very
awkwardly placed after black positions
the bishop on B7 you're gonna threaten
Bishop takes F3 and white is potentially
gonna have to burn more Tempe uh to
retract The Rook from this illegal
parking spot yeah I I really don't get a
good feeling
um from Rook takes G5 because uh one of
the reasons I liked Knight takes G5 was
that B6 could be restrained by the idea
of Queen F3 Our Queen now now can never
join the action because the knights in
the way and the Knight has to stay in
the way because it's guarding the Rook
so you get this weird like geometry and
like piece configuration I don't think
it works out very well for for Jabba so
I'm actually wondering now do we just
have to move the Rook again almost like
Rook back to G3
and if that's the case I don't know if I
really like the position just imagine a
few moves happen on the board and black
achieves Bishop B7 Knight F6 Rook comes
to C8 the E4 square is is loose The
Bishop's great on B7 suddenly I start to
love Black's position so I think rajaba
is really Under Pressure now he's
created a position where I think he
needs a couple really accurate moves
here with white
yeah I'm gonna go out and say that Rook
takes G5 I think is a pretty serious
inaccuracy
um I I think Timor underestimated the
speed with which black could not only
completes his development but creates
concrete threats against White's pieces
the bishop the Knight on F3 we mentioned
that whites King is relatively safe I
stand by what I said but that doesn't
mean that white has suffered no
consequences for pushing the Jeep on the
structural Integrity of White's position
is definitely compromised the pieces are
loose the files are open and white can't
dilly-dally forever so I think Timor
underestimated uh the speed of Black's
development and the extent to which it's
going to be difficult for white uh to
handle his King side affairs with this
Rook just kind of sitting on G5 and
taking the knights rightful spot
so I have an issue with the queen on D1
I'm looking at the move Pawn to D5
strangely enough
um I'd I'd like to try to place my queen
maybe on the D4 Square behind it and D5
also plays against perhaps the idea of
Bishop B7 in the sense that I don't know
what's happening after you know part
takes pawn and you know the Knight might
be hanging on D7 and things get really
wild here so
yeah obviously uh this is well well
calculated you have seven King it so
you're calculating it uh ef7 King H7
yeah I was looking yeah
obviously yeah
um just Madness there but the one thing
about D5 is that it finds a way to enter
the queen into action without having to
move that Knight so that was that's the
really the only uh aggressive move that
I would still find difficult to handle
with the black pieces
yeah uh Bishop B7 is one move I suppose
Knight C5 would be another way to to
secure the E6 spawn but I agree Queen D4
uh there's a pretty scary Prospect of
White Moving the king maybe up to E2 as
you had indicated before and then
doubling on the G file the pressure on
G7 uh could could grow unbearable very
very fast so I really like your proposal
my guess is that if Timor is thinking
about D5 what he has to calculate first
and foremost is indeed Bishop B7 like
this line that we kind of jokingly
showed is actually very likely to appear
on the board true if uh D5 is played but
see more if we uh go back to the current
position is down to seven minutes and 50
seconds D5 is on the board and you
called it my friend
yeah I think it's one of those positions
where if you don't play D5
the other moves that seem like they're
available to White are I don't know
Bishop D3 Rook G3 and these moves are
just not in the spirit of the position I
think rajaba felt his position was
getting a little bit worse like the tide
was turning and the only way it seems to
justify Rook takes G5 instead of Knight
takes appears to be D5 to me and the
reason I didn't delve deeper into the
complications after Bishop B7 is that if
Arjun doesn't play Bishop B7 I don't
want to do any bonus work in that
position yeah so let's wait let's wait
and see if he plays Bishop B7 then we're
gonna embrace the complications and you
know jump head first into the pool but
Bishop B7 is far from the only move
Knight C5 uh seems to be the computer
stop choice to protect the E6 Pawn maybe
prepare to get into E4
and uh you know suddenly two more is
down to seven minutes and 50 seconds and
this is after you know all of the
impressive preparation so now that's
another factor which we're gonna start
talking about in about two or three
minutes you know the we're starting to
enter the time pressure phase slowly but
surely
and I don't think he uh got up to the
point of Queen H6 which is interesting
because Queen H6 made a lot of sense to
me
um to get ahead of White's Queen ending
up on H5
um so I thought Queen H6 by Arjun was a
a very like natural human kind of
resource to to locate but perhaps had he
kept you know the had he kept the
preparation going a little bit further
you might have seen ah okay Knight takes
G5 is the move we can give up H2 and
those lines we were calculating earlier
but suddenly it felt like he was on his
own at the board Rook takes G5 felt more
natural and now he's in a position where
he has invested that time and things
will get very wild here I'm looking at
Arjun and if you're thinking about
Bishop B7 you're spending a lot of time
to to calculate it otherwise it was like
Knight C5 and even Knight F6 perhaps
they just feel like
um less work uh as black to calculate
yeah that's more like you know Soviet
Schoolboy kind of style you know just
avoid avoid completions you know make
normal move uh even even e65 is uh not
totally out of the question
getting uh control of the D4 square and
Arjun indeed putting on his Soviet
Schoolboy hat throwing the Knight onto
C5
and my biggest question is what he
intends in response to Queen D4 that I
think is what Tim Moore is probably
gonna play
taking on E6 serves no purpose for white
um you want to leave that pawn there so
that when you recapture maybe with the
bishop you're hitting the Rook on A8 but
right now
I think the most important thing for
white is Queen D4 and if you look at all
the pieces the last piece that just
hasn't done anything that Rook on A1 so
I want to play Queen D4 I wanna well
maybe King E2 is the best place for the
king but that Rook on A1 Danny I think
if it swings over to G1 then White's
position really starts to look dangerous
and Arjun has to act fast
Arjun has two moves and there's so many
things the menu is best uh you could
play Bishop B7 and go like Rook 88 but
that doesn't strictly prevent white from
achieving the ideal setup if you want to
take more drastic measures you can
contemplate the move F6 but that creates
major weaknesses along the A2 G8
diagonal so I wouldn't pay too much heed
to the eval bar here I think that if
anything like if we take the span of the
next two moves Black's position is more
difficult to play if Arjun can solve
this problem successfully then you know
I'll be the first to say that you know
the position is objectively good for
black but but can he figure out a way uh
to take the sting out of King E2 and
Rook ag1 which are two very obvious
follow-up moves yeah I think we're back
to them the what we were alluding to
earlier where we were saying you know
this is maybe dangerous or good prep
because from Black's perspective you're
sitting there looking at a position
where you can find your opponent's moves
easier than you can find your own and
that's not a good feeling when you're
sitting at the chess board and you're
like you almost want to turn the table
around wait a minute this position looks
kind of nice I wouldn't mind
um so yeah this this does look like can
you do Rook G1 if I'm looking at Black's
position I mean first of all F6
is the first it's the first move that
comes to my mind
um just to calculate Pawn to F6 which
means it must be correct wait of course
my instincts are unrivaled and parallel
um because E6 is defended of course if
you played Pawn to F6 maybe you want to
bring an analysis board because it might
get a little confusing here but Pawn
takes pawn and you know if you go and
grab that Rook then I just don't know
what's happening on Pawn E7 right and it
might get a little weird here
total and absolute chaos this would be
necessary because Bishop E6 runs into
Rook takes C5 that's not a prospect the
black wants to allow but Arjun
refraining from F6 and you know staying
a more conventional course with Bishop
B7 and this just makes me more and more
curious what he has in mind against King
E2 now Timur could also Castle Queen
side but I think that would have more
downsides than upsides black could stick
at a rook on C8 yeah and then black
would already be threatening Knight B3
so I think E2 is relatively the safest
Square on the chessboard
for the white King right now
absolutely you need to
um and it has to be somewhere like King
D1 King F1 we're not considering because
the Rook needs to get to G1 there's no
way around that no um
yeah if Rich G1 is very hard to uh
that's a sneaky little defense there so
that's very teamwork actually has to
burn a Tempo taking on D5 but then then
there's like Bishop A6 Jack right and
things get really messy
and that was the downside of King E2 now
look there wasn't a better place to put
that King so I don't think King E2 was a
mistake but
um if Bishop A6 happens all of a sudden
your king is running everywhere like
King D2 you're in the middle of the war
terrible
that would be Unthinkable I think Rook
takes G7 and Rook G1 is forced I can see
why the evil bar is giving zeros I think
this line Rook takes Rook G1
some sort of it looks like black gets a
kingdom and a horde
for the queen but there's fortunately
for what a Perpetual check when she
foreign H5 in the classic
this looks very plausible at the moment
I think this is very likely going to be
the way that this game ends uh with with
this Perpetual I think Timur sees that
this is in his pocket uh he's verifying
that Bishop takes D5 out of the question
and it is
yeah and there it is
a drawn game one yeah this this can't
really go any other way because if white
gets ambitious and says okay I've got
the draw let me go for more first of all
you've got two Rooks and a bishop that
say otherwise in exchange for the queen
yeah and the Knight on G1 is not
necessarily you know entering with force
from from the G1 squid it's not exactly
making its presence making the black
pieces Shake in there
you know in their houses no uh but it's
actually it's actually Arjun uh taking
his time here maybe contemplating
flirting with a move like Rook F to d8
which I think is not uh the dumbest
decision to make I mean black currently
has two Rooks for the queen which you
could consider to be a small material
advantage the reason I think Arjun is
going to go for the draw first of all
this is game one he's got the black
pieces it draws a solid result uh no
need for crazy risks but the second
thing is that Black's King is just
permanently going to be weak and if this
Knight actually rejoins Society I'm on
the queen of night combo is a force to
be reckoned with and I don't think the
situation in the match calls for this
level of a risk but I agree people make
me my words agreed totally
um I think that uh and we do see the
draw on the board the the worst thing
that you can do is try to play this arm
and get ambitious when you shouldn't and
I think it's just a prudent match
strategy take the points that are
available on the board it is a draw both
players know it and go on to game two
where Arjun will get the white pieces
yeah that was a really really
interesting game uh kind of what we
predicted the players are close in
strength it was a fighting draw uh and
Timur did his best I mean great
preparation I think that critical moment
the critical moment was not playing
Knight takes G5 and we can now confirm
with the engine the Knight takes u5 was
indeed the path to uh to an advantage
Queen takes H2 and now simply King E2 uh
to coordinate the queen and the Rook
while simply in quotes
obviously dropped back to F3 and it's
clear that it's plus one of course
you've dropped the pieces back and
removed them from the attack
how Timur could not have noticed that is
is really Beyond me uh but after Rook
takes G5 a good reaction by Arjun to
secure the draw in game one he'll have
the white pieces in our second match
game
and uh the time has come as we look at
the scoreboard here only one match today
to round off a round of 32 we're gonna
go on a short break ladies and gentlemen
do not go anywhere because rajaba versus
Eric icy in our final round of 32
matchup here at the chess.com Global
Championship resumes on the other side
of this short
foreign
there on your left swinging in his
swivel chair awaiting the start of game
two and of course where would we be
without the top of two more rajabobs
chair here at the chess.com Global
Championship our final match in the
round of 32 alongside Grandmaster Iman
Hamilton I'm on let's take a quick look
at Arjun aragaisy's player card
he's only 19 years old and yet his
resume is absolutely packed and his
rating is only going up
indeed I mean one of the things that
certainly stands out on this card is the
chess.com Junior speed Chess
Championship like being the champion of
that event Daniel there are so many
talented players that first of all are
Juniors nowadays but that were in this
event so to me that's an incredible
achievement in its own right and you
almost don't even get the full picture
of knowing who is in that event for him
to win it but any any Junior
championship title
um whether it's online which is more
common nowadays posted by chess.com or
even the world junior Championship uh in
real life incredible incredibly uh
prestigious title there
and that MPL senior Championship that
you see is the official name for the
Indian Championship so our generic IC
has been on such a rampage I think he
also won the Sharjah Masters a couple of
months ago uh a field that included
something like 40 or 50 Grand Masters
and he seems to do it all with this kind
of effortless air he has such a such a
light style you know I don't even know
how to characterize it but I think you
know what I'm saying it just seems to be
just going with the flow making natural
moves and before you know it he's just
uh torn you know six grand Masters to
bits in a row
I I agree I think nonchalant comes to
mind
um the way that the way that he plays I
couldn't agree more it's it's as if he's
got it figured out and even if he
doesn't he's not concerned and I I think
that he doesn't tilt and that plays into
it as well you just don't ever see that
concern look of concern on his face when
he loses a game if he gets out played
that's just the way it is he sort of
takes it on the chin learns from it and
he comes straight back with a vengeance
as we see the next game has just gotten
underway
and we have a Berlin we have the new
team or rajabov who uh played the Berlin
successfully in the candidates
tournament I don't think that we had a
single Berlin end game in the candidates
D takes C5 by Argin is he trying to
force a draw here in game two
yeah I mean if you're a job of you're
not saying no to this this is a really
well-known draw in chess Pawn takes on
Passau on D6 Queen captures but he
doesn't want to go for it and rajaba was
probably like huh I don't I've never
seen this move in my life
a lot of people forget that this is this
line has existed for many years it's a
pretty old school line I used to play
this with white
um and I used to play this with Queen to
D3 in this position but you can also uh
play A5 and try to clamp down on the
queen side light squares so almost
nobody knows that uh there exists some
Sidelines in this position that do not
involve taking on the sun and going for
the Drone Arjun is going for one of them
I'm taking my hat off I like this yeah
this is what the world needs more of
it it's really really nice first of all
you can know that this draw exists and
just pick a different line and avoid it
all together and then you know you might
get a golf clap as people say oh that's
nice he's playing on he's playing for
something but I think you get an extra
loud Round of Applause when you walk all
the way up to the potential draw and
then say no right at the last moment you
know he he basically is one move away
from potentially having a repetition on
the board and you know it's a little bit
of a mind game he says nope I'm actually
gonna play this position right here he
goes for your move A5 and hey if we see
those dark Square Bishops Bishop on C1
and Bishop on E7 if we see those trade
off the board at all that White's
position is going to look tremendous
yeah gee I wonder you know what kinds of
squares Arjun is trying to control with
his last two moves I don't know A5 and
B4 maybe the dark scores on the queen
side uh this could be a very dangerous
strategy if you give white like three
more moves he sticks tonight on A4 maybe
he feels the bishop as you're saying if
the dark squared Bishops disappear from
the board that is an ideal scenario for
white because then white has a complete
Monopoly over the queen side dark
squares
yep so I mean Black's plan that he's
gonna be going for is very simple wants
to Castle if they can use safety I think
he also is looking for in the future
maybe they move F6 castles and F6 for
black once the tread pry the position
open remember black is the one that has
the bishop pair here so he would do well
to open things in the center you alluded
to this in the previous game Daniel when
it was a little more evident but here I
think it applies as well white is still
playing on the side of the board A4 A5
B4 and when that happens you generally
want to open things in the middle
yeah F6 looks very tempting to me even
in this position
um if we bring up an analysis board it's
not so easy for white uh to react
appropriately to that now obviously
Arjun is still in his prep I'm sure he
has F6 analyze maybe he wants Bishop F4
but an example of how you could get in
trouble would be the natural looking
Bishop B2 oh let's prepare the battery
well the problem that after traffic 5
Queen E5 Bishop F6 you can simply resign
because the bishop on B2 is skewered
or the queen is skewered so that's
invalid F4 Amman is similarly bad
because after Fe you have to take with a
pawn and allow this type of move and now
your Pawn's weak yeah so my guess is
that Arjun has Bishop F4 in his pocket
in response to M6 but we might see this
yeah if we see F6 I think we'll see
Bishop F4 really quickly
um the move in 92 is is an interesting
one but I think it's also a little bit
that you might want to solidify the the
B4 Pawn maybe with upon a C3
um and of course now that the knights on
E2 you can definitely think about moves
like Knight F4 and perhaps the Knight
goes back to D3 so yeah he does go C3 in
reaction to Bishop F5
um on the queen side Daniel I think the
game revolves a little bit around you
know can black get the moves D6 and C5
because if you can then you know White's
position suddenly looks silly because
you've wasted all this time moving all
these pawns out here saying oh you can't
do this you can't do that and black just
goes and does it well then none of none
of your your gameplay thus far makes
sense it's like those movie scenes where
you put all these objects against the
doors the bad guy can't get in you know
another bad guy just gets in through
another door uh yeah if Blacklist B65 I
agree completely and uh the reason B6
isn't valid here is that after a b a b
the queen is overloaded so white trades
Rooks and then wins The Pawn on B6
that's a but that's a pretty flimsy
mechanism with which to prevent B6 and
perhaps that's why Arjun uh we want to
put a little bit more meat on the bone
on the next move Bishop B3 comes to mind
as a way to deter B6 further but of
course the downside of that uh is that
the bishop could also potentially be
required on F4 all right so White's
Bishop has a pretty big weight on its
shoulders uh to support the center and
to prevent Black's Queen side expansion
at the same time
yeah and um one move that might come to
mind after let's say white goes Bishop
E3 it could be the move A6 but it's
really important for for black not to
play the move A6 because that kills
everything that we've been talking about
all these all these B6 C5 ideas No in
fact A6 is exactly what white would love
to see because now there's no Pawn
advance that can happen without being
captured which means that Black's pawns
all four of them are basically immobile
and they're immobilized by three pawns
from White so that's a real achievement
to have your three pawns on the queen
side neutralize four from your opponent
yeah that's a great point in fact both
sides want the other side to put upon
them to be the one to put upon an A6 uh
from the opposite perspective white
certainly doesn't want to play A6
because that merely accelerates uh you
know the nightmare process of black
blank B6 and C5 so white wants to keep
the status quo on the queen side
you know black doesn't mind the status
quo as long as he can get B6 and
eventually
but I think what Tim Moore is really
thinking about here is this move F6 I
think he's still trying to decide
whether he wants this additional source
of tension or does he want to keep the
position closed and play a more kind of
non-descript improving move like Queen
D7
yeah and queen D7 also relinquishes the
B6 Square so it it does kind of say okay
I'm not gonna go for that plan right now
or maybe in the foreseeable future one
thing to keep in mind look maybe it's
the Yas or influence but if that Rook on
A8 ever moves do you play Queen D7
rookie eight how quickly am I now
snapping that pawn on A7 don't think
that just because it's there uh you know
on the side of the board I'm not gonna
grab it Daniel wow I remember when I
captured Robert Huebner spawned on A7
and you know that Robert adjusted his
glasses and you know and that thick
German accent of his said I lost upon I
remember those days but uh yeah it's a
tough position for Timur not only is
white slightly better on the board he's
uh building up a huge advantage on the
clock look at the clock situation 1446
for Arjun who's just sitting back in his
chair just kind of another day in the
office I'm bored yeah totally two more
is laboring over the position what do I
do queen D7 F6 arjun's just nonchalant
that's the word he used before the game
and I think that word is sounding just
about perfect right now
because even if this game ends in a draw
I mean it's a draw that Arjun couldn't
care less about and it's a Traw that
rajabov has you know worked his tail off
the whole game to achieve so just in
terms of the match I mean you talk about
energy and and just like uh expending
energy look at what is happening right
now I mean this is just sets up Arjun
for the next couple games as well I
think it's definitely the case that you
generally have like a limited amount and
I think Arjun is is saving for uh later
games and he's definitely going to be uh
more fresh when it when it comes to uh
rounds three and four yeah we've seen
some great preparation from both players
the difference is that this position is
a lot less Dynamic uh than the previous
one so if Arjun has accounted for all
the ideas if he has a road map for where
to put his dark squid Bishop he could
foreseeably be playing quickly the next
couple of moves as well
timur's got to make a decision he's down
seven and a half minutes on the clock
we're only on move 14 the position is
still completely closed her job of is
not going to survive a bullet game in
this position no I mean it's more than
more than half the time I mean are you
really ever satisfied with a position
when you have to think about it like
this you know I mean this this
definitely definitely something wrong
with your position I've never seen these
thinking pose so this this immediately
tells me that there's issues here and
he's gone with B6 which is really
interesting yes oh my lands that is a
very serious decision Iman I have to beg
your pardon I I have to disappear for 10
seconds I have to get
request approved
um the reason that Danny and I were
unsure about this B6 move is ironically
because of exactly what's appearing on
the board and that's actually an
interesting phenomenon that happens
sometimes in chess is you calculate a
line you're like okay this can't happen
or my opponent can't do this because
of this and you calculate it out and
you're like okay yep I've calculated
that well there's no way my opponent can
do it and then that feeling sinks in
where they do it anyway
they just play the exact thing that
you've just spent your your time
calculating you're feeling confident
about it and then they just play it and
that's what's happened here job
obviously B6 and if you look at the
position on the board The Rook down on
A1 which is by the way now hanging can
take the rook in the top left corner on
A8 the queen would then take back and
Danny and I talked about how the pawn on
B6 is hanging it'll be a free pawn and
in fact we Loosely discussed how that
pawn would just be hanging and that's
why he couldn't go for this
and now he's gone for it so I I was uh
really surprised to see this but it
means that rajaba didn't really love his
position and he wants a forcing way to
deal with what's happened on the board
he doesn't want to sit there play a long
game with the time disadvantage he's
like let's solve everything right now um
and he's calculated something up and the
other thing I think one has to bear in
mind is the song cost effect right when
you've invested
six and a half minutes even if you start
becoming pessimistic about the move
you've just spent six minutes
calculating you've just spent six
minutes calculating it right so then to
play a slow move just doesn't make any
logical sense because then you know why
didn't you just make that move
immediately and then you're more likely
you're a lot more likely to make the
forcing move the longer and the more
amount of time you invest on it
so I think uh even speaking for myself a
really bad habit that chess players get
into is spending five minutes
calculating a move
and then you know four minutes into that
three minutes into that you're only
calculating one move if you're only
calculating one thing you should
probably play it and then calculate it
right unless you're considering multiple
options you're just wasting your time
exactly so so let's blow up an analysis
board let's let's forecast how we think
the game is going to go first question
does Arjun have any serious alternatives
to Rook A8 we need maybe six and this
even need to find Alternatives like
what's the evaluation here
yeah I mean I think you start with the
most forcing
um and when your opponent kind of hands
you upon so to speak you got to
investigate what they're calculating so
Queen takes
um yeah Bishop D3 one of the first
things that I look at
or queen E3 I guess Queen E3 is a more
Tempo move
foreign
although I guess I plays rookie one and
asked yeah where exactly the
compensation is
and uh
I'm I hope someone has the answer but I
certainly don't know where did it go I
see it it's on the left on the right
but rookie one of course is also
possible here then maybe black can sneak
a queen into A1
something like that you know could be
what Timur is aiming for I can believe
that a little bit more
but I'm skeptical I think Arjun should
take on B6 and call Tim Moore's Bluff
well here's the thing how do you not
take the pawn if you go back to the
position before Rook A8 it's like what
reasonable way do I have to not take the
pawn I mean if you go Bishop to E3 Pawn
to C5 will happen it doesn't matter if
the queen for black is on d8 or on A8
it's going to be guarding the D5 pawn
and C5 can happen and I don't know that
I don't really trust any position where
black achieves D5 or black achieved C5
excuse me it's the right triangle
um it's this position is totally
colorless right if if Arjun goes for
this that basically means he's admitting
that you know he doesn't have too many
Ambitions to win this game because black
will park you know even the bishop on E6
Queen D7 this is as solid as it gets and
this would kind of signify that the
failure of White's entire middle game
strategy not to sound too dramatic but
that's exactly what it would be
so with every ticking second Amman I
think the same logic can be applied to
arjun's decision it's likelier and
likelier that he's going to grab the
pawn on B6
right and I mean I love your analogy
from earlier with the white playing like
uh C3 B4 A5 it really is like you put
every piece of furniture against the
door and then it just so happens that
that door like opens outwards
yeah exactly now you just have B6 played
and it's like wait what I could do that
anyway I mean what else does white have
to do to stop the move B6
yeah A5 before and I think uh we hit the
nail on the head there there it is I
mean takes B6 on the board it's C5
Knight F4 instantly follows
oh so that was timor's idea was to play
C5 and try to trap White's Queen on B6
yeah or at the very least maybe it
wouldn't be trapped but it'd certainly
be a great position for black because
even if we have you know the A5 Square
available the resulting positions are
not going to be good for white as we see
the pawn on C5 even at the cost of a
pawn for black so crucial to get that
because you start controlling all the
squares that white wants to use
and Arjun instantly responding with
Knight F4 I think he was tired of having
to deal with Bishop D3 uh and he
believes that after rugby eight Queen C7
the queen doesn't have a lot of
retreating squares but it is an
incredibly slippery piece people
underestimate how difficult the queen is
to trap in any position
Queen C7 Rook B7 would have happened the
queen would have had the C6 Square as
well instead Timor he trades on B4 and
now he plays Rook B8 are we heading for
just like a mass liquidation of some
sort in a draw
well
um so Queen A5 is
is one of the moves I'm looking at
because I'm I'm trying to get rid of the
queen on A8 so that the D5 Pawn hangs
um so if you go Queen A5 and like trade
or if white gets to trade on A8 take on
D5 I think we're pretty happy there
um
trying to see if there are other
Alternatives that I would really go for
but it seems dangerous for white to try
to play this position uh losing the B4
Pawn like if it turns into black keeping
the d-pawn then perhaps I get even a bit
concerned
oh yeah totally with it with a bishop
pair and you know that pawn could appear
on D3 in the blink of an eye I think
Arjun needs to do everything in his
power to either keep the bee Pawn alive
as you're saying or trade the beep on
for the d-pawn the good thing for Timor
though Amman is even in an end game
where there's a four on three and black
is the bishop error I feel like Tim
Moore should be able to hold a draw
there
totally agree
um that that looks
that looks like enough uh apart from
Queen A5
the only other move I'm looking at is
Queen C7 and there might be some like
Tactical justifications for how we can
take on D5 like Queen C7 Bishop takes on
B4 and Knight takes D5 and you know
there's a 97 check that that I've got in
my pocket I got six and The Rook is
still loose on the back rank there I
think we're likely to get a kind of
position like this and this is basically
unusable given the control the black has
over the light squares the White's never
gonna get a pawn past F4 uh with the
Queen's honor even though the Queen's
off so this is one possibility I think
another possibility is Queen A5 and your
black can contemplate something like D4
and before you know it this could get
very double edged I mean agreed I think
you called it him on you know black can
keep the Deep on the pawn count matters
a lot less in these types of end games
uh you know then the quality of the
passers that you have
yeah that's that's a great way to say it
um if I'm Arjun here I don't want to
deal with this we see the time situation
evening up completely so you talk about
your job off and how he looked like he
was struggling earlier well in fact he
may have just been working all this out
because he didn't want to sit there play
a long game as we said he wanted to
simplify things on the spot he did
exactly that now if I'm white I love the
move Queen to C7 because it's more
forcing it hits the bishop on E7 we want
Knight takes D5 and although the queen
is also protecting the D5 Square for
black it's it has an alternative job
which is protecting a rook on V8
unfortunately that's far more important
so you can can't really take back there
I don't know I think depending the ponds
are more important debatable me
yeah I think Bishop before Knight D5 is
probably what's going through rajabov's
uh rajabov's brain at this time Bishop
takes before is on the board
and I'm gonna give this a 90 likelihood
of one way or another physically added
to a draw yeah and we saw that in the
last game as well Dania like the the
willingness to just take that draw from
both sides
um and in this game Queen C7 not Queen
A5 I feel like the players they both
know what's on the line here right this
is the the final match of the round of
32 moving on to the round of 16 would be
huge for either player so they don't
really want to take unnecessary risks
they they can see the draws the most
likely result and they're gonna they're
gonna take the safe option here that
looks like in game two because such a
close match Daniel that just one mistake
could swing the whole match
oh yeah it absolutely can I mean this is
game two the worst thing to do is lose
with the white pieces against someone as
solid uh as either of these players one
question I'm having though is that after
Knight takes D5 could black contemplate
the move Bishop F5 to D3
is this perhaps what worries Arjun the
idea is to attack the rook and if you
move the Rook to D1 I wanted to follow
up with Bishop E2
and that Rook is very constricted if you
have to play Rook D4 then you've exposed
your back rank I feel like the pieces
are loose this just doesn't seem like
the way to go Rook C8 uh skewer is the
queen of the bishop
wow yeah that gets uh really tricky all
of a sudden and Knight takes B4 I guess
doesn't
do that much yeah you can take on D1
there's this move
this is the Saving Grace and then to
move the Rook
and then to move the Rook well the queen
has nowhere to go you have to play Queen
B7 well no I guess we can be someone
loses because now you can at the very
least take take a rook d8 bishop f8 and
whoop this is uh I mean this is like a
wild line do they want Bishop to A5
at which point like uh after Knight B6 I
mean they they like all all computer
entities like all robotic people in the
world I want this oh my God I'm on you
want to know how the line continues you
will not you will not believe this oh my
God I have to show this E6
Bishop takes B6 no we're not even
getting started Queen takes F7 King h8
now you play E7
of course Bishop takes D1 Bishop B2
threatening Checkmate black throws and
Bishop takes F2 check to distract
White's gang white says no no no
Rook G8 and now the cherry on top Bishop
takes G7 and EA Queen this is the Top
Line the top Engine line in that
position
how do the players not see this honestly
I mean honestly a huge mistake if I got
it out
put that one in puzzle rush I tell you
that'll be the only one yeah this is
like a 3800 rated problem
good Lauren okay well anyways we'll
we'll simplify things for you guys and
say hey guess what that didn't happen
that didn't happen Bishop is on the
board a little more logical because the
whole Knight takes D5 move Daniel relies
on stuff like this and if you don't see
25 moves ahead sorry you can't play
Knight takes D5 with confidence that was
just an incredible line I definitely
something to revisit if you're a student
of the game
um and and chess is so unique in that
you have these two parallel games them
on you have what happens on the board
which is plenty entertaining but you
also have what remains behind the scenes
and that has a certain Beauty and charm
of its own you could basically fill
entire volumes
um I know the late Yuri averback uh his
his Memoir was titled something like
behind the scenes of Chess Beauty so
it's it's just like a parallel universe
that you can trace as well but
speaking of uh the current Universe
after something like Bishop C3 is black
not at this point slightly better is
black not the one pushing for a win here
I I think the tables have definitely
turned
um rajabov is still I mean he's still
spending his time here
um and I think his position is actually
easier to play so I'd like to see him
speed up but Bishop C3 Honda D4 is
lurking E5 Pawn is hanging
two Bishops we talked about this Daniel
if black can hang onto that d-pawn I
love your job off's chances
because the red carpet is unrolled right
you have both Bishops controlling
essentially every square up until the
promotion Square D4 d3d2 all three of
these are controlled by one of Black's
Bishops what does that mean that
basically means white has to preserve
his control over the D4 square and that
control is very flimsy indeed because
the queen is not a reliable Defender
it's incredibly vulnerable black has
several ways to chase it off of that
diagonal
and if I'm Argent I'm I'm seriously
considering you know taking rather
drastic measures moves like E6
uh at this point need to be
and seriously calculated maybe Rook D1
as well if if you want to throw a move
on the board like sure just just H3 or
something for white to illustrate your
point
um and it's probably easier within I
guess with an analysis bar it's going to
say D4 by black and actually what
happens after D4 might be Bishop takes
and then I was thinking of Rook C6 and
I'm trying to kick that Queen off the
way you're talking about the only Square
available is 87 to offer a trade so
you're right you've got to maintain
control of this square but I find the
move that we see on the board right now
Daniel to be crazy in this regard
because it does the opposite in fact it
invites D4 Queen B5 I totally don't get
that neither it is rajabov who has
indeed sped up I think what arjun's
saying is his control over D4 was so
unreliable that he actually prefers to
control the D3 square but at this point
his fingers are starting to slip away
from the ledge and I'm thinking about
moves like Queen E4 if the pawn appears
on D3 that could be an immediate death
sentence or Arjun yeah part on D3 is too
much to handle and I mean so much though
ladies play Queen C6 I don't like the
move Queen B5 by white I also don't
really love to move Queen C6 although I
think rajabov has a little bit uh I
think he's a wider birth for potentially
error here Queen C6 while it may not be
the best move Look Black's still going
to get the same kind of game he wants to
push that pawn I don't think there's
anything stopping remember once those
Queens trade Dania imagine a bishop on
C2 you talked about escorting that pawn
well Bishop C2 Bishop C3 those are the
the perfect bouncers to to have outside
your Club
oh a great way to put it and I'm
thinking of taking and going Knight to
D5 here which is indeed what Arjun plays
the threat is a fork on E7 and after
rookie six do you take on C3 because on
the one hand it leads to an opposite
colored Bishop ending that's encouraging
on the other hand it allows the C Pawn
to entrench itself on C2 where it will
basically survive the apocalypse yeah I
mean that that that's a forever Pawn I I
don't get a good feeling Dania about
Knight takes C3 even though it might be
the engine's recommendation I'm not sure
it really doesn't feel good
the engine is okay with it the top move
is actually Rook to D1 which is not easy
to play that threatens Knight takes C3
and Rook d8 mate
it all seems so obvious when you know
the move is played on the board but my
human instinct would be to play F4
I'm a mere human a blunder yeah
horrendous it's unacceptable how dare
you defend the Central Pawn on E5 with
another one basically is the move F4
connected with Knight takes Bishop like
if you play off four are you gonna have
to play Knight takes on C3 I think black
might do well to maybe play the move H5
here
um but let's just say Bishop E4 is
played to attack the Knight I'm just
wondering is it Knight takes C3 because
if it is then then I guess that plays
into why
um you know the engine doesn't really
love move F4 yep and and also if you
combine these two moves the second rank
becomes a major weakness so you could
Envision a reality a future reality
where black just like swings a rook to
A2
and you know there's a lot of enemies at
White's door uh there's the pawn
potentially on C2 there's the weak weak
Pawn on G2 Bishop E4 is indeed on the
board Knight takes C3
and this is basically 50 50. I think
between a draw and a black win
yeah I I think we're gonna see you know
Bishop to F5
Pont H5
black king is gonna sort of weasel its
way to H7 uh G6 and maybe slowly try to
get into position and you called it The
Rook looks like it wants to swing to A6
to A2
um or even A1 as as you you pointed out
there so uh love Black's chances here
and I think it's really important for
everyone watching uh to appreciate the
engine eval but not uh you know listen
to it entirely because I think rajabov's
chances here are way higher than what's
being represented by the eval bar I I
agree although I think I mean I I would
evaluate this from a human perspective
as maybe plus two something maybe like a
60 40 situation um capablanca actually
advocated for that form of evaluation uh
in the pre-computer era you just speak
in terms of percentage like what is the
percentage black wins what is the
percentage that the game ends in a draw
uh and the the closer Arjun arjun's
clock gets to zero the harder this
becomes to defend another thing a month
that the engine won't tell you is that
black and torture White
add infinitive like you could make 50
moves easily in this position it's not
like those positions where you know
there's a three or four move stretch and
if you survive it then you basically
make a draw here you have to survive uh
you know 50 moves of torture with tons
of threats and the possibility of black
promoting
and the engine has this ability where
you know it's almost like a coin flip
every coin flip you do is like
completely independent of the previous
one so like every good move the engine
has to make is independent of the
previous moves it'll always be able to
find the best move whereas you know for
the human playing a position like this
it's like if you have to play 50 good
moves in a row every single one becomes
less and less likely that you're gonna
mate
that's a that's a fantastic point and
not not to mention that your time keeps
sticking Down The Rook has appeared on a
A4 what is it doing there well
potentially consistency for you can't
play King F3 right now because of the
pin that's why Arjun plays H3 securing
the G4 Square
my guess is that Timur is gradually
going to start getting his King out of
the shell Amman I don't know which
direction he's gonna go to the king side
to the center but I think black needs
his King
yeah the King has to make an appearance
one thing that I love about rajav's
technique here is the Pawn on C3 is not
on C2 I think a lot of players be really
eager to get that pawn to a square where
it's protect it but look at how it's
dominating the bishop the Brooklyn A4
and the pawn on C3 mean I mean that
Bishop doesn't have anywhere to go
basically nope right so it's totally
dominated you've got the pawn covering
dark squares the bishop covering light
squares the pawn on H4 is even taking
away a crucial dark Square I love how
her job has found a way to control both
uh color complexes with his pawns bishop
and Rogue oh and Bishop D2 but white
hangs by a thread CD Rook A1 Bishop C2
the king drops back to E2 just in time
rajaba though he's down to 23 seconds I
think he has to go back to A3 yep and we
have a repetition here obviously two
more it's not just gonna yield the draw
no he's got to try to get Arjun to you
know 15 20 seconds I think that's a
critical step toward winning the game
right
um I mean yeah bringing the king looks
uh looks solid enough
okay this does look totally reasonable I
wouldn't pay attention to the minor
swings of the eval bar here unless it
swings to zero uh black has you know
four or five moves in each position that
are approximately equivalent Bishop
before King F5 is coming
I think this is close to over the toilet
yeah yeah I I just don't see first of
all the time is gonna be a huge Factor
you have Richie three and I think it's
resignable Arjun needs to try to set
some sort of a trap ooh he doesn't play
Rook G3 but this is plenty sufficient I
think
I think he might have a game plan in
mind like if he goes Rook B1 all of a
sudden it's like a frozen position for
white and if he plays Rook B1 And Trades
the Rooks even Bishop takes G2 might win
the game
and he does take on G2 immediately
yeah that cost of his C Pawn still I I
think you know he's just chosen a
winning path and he kind of feels good
about it so
um I think it's all right F5 last ditch
attempt by Arjun it's not over yet
though
that age one still has to promote and
now Arjun has created for himself a
passer of his own
but what are such a strong against dg6
yeah King G6 so so good because you see
that Bishop just can't handle the h-bond
no but can The Rook handle it
should be four
well the the thing is about this
position is uh the Rook is now stuck on
the H file and I don't see what you do
about Black's King just entering the
game maybe G5 happening as well
yeah King E4 also again black is in
absolutely no hurry because once the
king moves the black Bishop is
controlling
the destiny of my T-Bone oh that is a
nasty move and a rook G3 would have
ended it
as does this this is resignable just
don't go Rook G3
and don't go H2 Rook B2 because it'll be
checked
Rook B2 first I think H2 is safe yeah
Bishop D4 is not as tricky as it looks
no you can basically go anywhere
but I think King F4
yeah working E6 King D7 is plenty it's
efficient
yeah you struck anywhere in Bishop F3
he's not going out uh just yet but man
what a well-played end game from rajav
who took his small small Edge and you
and I were calling it Danny I think it's
just too much nasty oh we take these
things for granted you know we look at a
game like this where Java kind of sits
back and like yeah I'm pretty awesome uh
we take these things for granted but but
to win that position with black we
thought that white held all the chances
at some point I mean before Tim Moore
played B6 he was seven minutes down
seven minutes down with a slightly worse
position he turned all of that around
and he did it in incredible fashion I
think in retrospect I'm on the decision
to play B6 was flat out genius it was it
was a genius idea
um and he was coupled with an idea that
um yeah I won't lump you in this
category just yet Daniel but I certainly
had no idea about the move C5 that was
so impressive didn't cross my mind so
strong wrong it was engine approved and
from there I think he just hopped in the
saddle and he never got off
he never did indeed before we go on
break to prepare for the third match
game we want to remind you that the cgc
finals the final eight will make their
way to Toronto at the start of November
the second through the seventh will
feature the cgc finals contesting a 1
million dollar prize fund in Toronto
with a an All-Star cast and crew
especially that third guy from the left
uh we're gonna have yeah I can't quite
make out the name but uh we'll leave you
to do that during the break but mark
your calendars ladies and Gentlemen even
if you can't show up in person
everything is going to be broadcast live
state of the art commentary and all the
action you could ask for at the start of
November but for now we are going to go
on a very short break here at the
chess.com Global Championship the final
round of 32 magic resumes in just a
couple of moments
foreign
[Music]
to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best we
are in for a wild ride and hey have we
mentioned there's also a million dollars
at stake the total pot is a million
dollars know that it's not a typo the
prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remains he knows exactly what's
about to happen oh my goodness this is
over a heartbreaker for Mr svidler Jana
probably she pulls through once again
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real oh gosh no time oh
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
and we see here Arjuna aragaisi and
Timur rajaba of today's Gladiators in
the cgc final match-up of 32 who will be
the last player to make it into the
final 16.
well tomorrow is making a pretty
compelling case that it should be him as
we review his match-up card alongside
Grandmaster Amman Hamilton Amman that
was an incredibly impressive performance
in the last game the more a job of is
just experiencing a years-long second
wind in his career
yeah that's a great way to put it total
Resurgence
um but the thing is I I don't think that
he's necessarily reaching a level that
we haven't seen before whereas some
people might feel that way this is more
of a Resurgence because rajabov has been
at the elite for such a long period of
time he's just getting back to where he
has been and you see that that match
against uh holy Fawn I mean such a
dominating uh performance against such a
strong player as well and I brought this
up earlier Dania it's so understated and
maybe underappreciated how difficult it
is to get into the candidates tournament
I mean the guy plays third in it so I
mean rajabov uh experiencing some really
recent success and especially in Rapid
time control format he's establishing
himself as one of the best he absolutely
is a couple of years ago he was down
below 2700 nobody was talking about him
and then during the heat of covet he won
a couple of online tournaments in
convincing fashion and you know he's
shown that that has been anything but a
fluke winning a Berlin with the black
pieces despite arjun's impressive
preparation and for our generic icy as
we get underway here I think it's very
important not to go crazy in this game
and this is where I think arjun's mental
level-headedness his toughness is going
to shine through the last thing you want
is you know to make an irrational
decision in the opening because quote
unquote you need to win and then lose
the entire match you actually don't need
to win a draw is not a disastrous result
in this game is it
no it's not and um I think Arjun has the
white pieces to look forward to in the
final game so actually a draw might even
be the best result here just to
neutralize uh a stream
okay oh yeah much better you actually
want to draw here preferable uh yeah
even if you have a winning position yeah
we saw rajabov is like he had this prep
that looked really dangerous now it
didn't materialize
um throughout the entire game but the
point is that Java is indicating he's
got some spice to him with the white
pieces right now and a win right here
for her job off it puts this match away
Daniel so if you want to keep this going
give yourself a chance with the white
pieces I think as Arjun you take your
chances as they come but you don't over
press
yeah no you're exactly right the current
score is one and a half a win uh would
get some more into the round of 16 and
it would mean the last game will not be
played
uh which uh puts obviously puts Origins
back against the wall so we have here a
semi-terrush a relatively popular
opening in recent years this has always
been uh considered very reputable and uh
we now have a hanging on structure which
is another old school you know type of
structure that's been around for many
decades
yeah this um I mean often you'll get
this kind of structure from an isolated
Pawn position which is I believe what
happened here as well so the B Pawn from
B2 joins C3 and then you get these
hanging pawns where black has really
easy and obvious places to put his Rooks
you know Rook d8 Rook C8 I mean you just
aim right at those two pawns obviously
but
um you know white suddenly has anchor
squares for his pieces a little bit more
space the E5 square and of course look
at those Bishops if you add the queen as
well
diagonals straight towards the castle
King
yeah it's actually one of those
situations where potentially both pairs
of Bishops uh could be staring at the
opposing side's king or black bishops on
B7 and D6 for white you know potential
Greek gift sacrifice ideas although it
should be pointed out I'm on that in in
such positions with the Knight on D7 the
the Greek gift sacrifice is virtually
impossible because anytime the queen
lands on H5
blacken respond to the simple Knight F6
protecting the H7 Square I think a lot
of people get so excited when they see a
possibility of a Greek gift sacrifice
that they fail to account for any
defensive option they're like oh my
Queen's on H5 it must be Checkmate
exactly
um I I think the checklist that I go
through in my head of course there are
always going to be positions where you
simply just need to calculate and there
are other resources which are harder to
spot but usually if number one there's
no night on F6 and number two you have a
Pawn on E5 as white that that's like
enough of a checklist to seriously
calculate Bishop takes H7 right there
yep so those are the two things I look
for here no Pawn on E5 generally does
mean that black will be safe castling
because the Knight can always reach F6
as you said
that's that's totally fair and if black
castles I'll show the line on the board
but Arjun is hesitating a little bit uh
my guess is that he's you know
confirming that white doesn't have any
Shenanigans after he castles maybe he's
also thinking about a somewhat more
flexible approach such as Rook C8 Bishop
F4 is another move that is a frequent
guest in these types of positions
trading off a pair of Bishops and in the
long run among the more pieces disappear
from the board the more concerning
White's Pawn structure becomes
especially in an end game I've seen a
lot of games go south or white uh just
because all of the pieces disappear from
the board and white is left of these uh
you know permanent stains exactly
yeah and important that black doesn't
just think oh I can Castle lean side
here because then C4 C5 prize open the
entire Queen side so
um still he goes for the move C4 but
definitely this game is going to be
about restricting those pawns the pawns
on B6 and the pawns on E6 for black are
the ones that keep white Central uh
pawns at Bay here there's no C5 there's
no D5 without at least answering the
Bell
um you know to all these pieces and
pawns that can capture it so I think
you'll probably see the pawns stay on C4
and D4 for a long period of time be
supported by the white pieces and as you
said Black's sort of looking for trades
Bishop F4 if those Bishops are exchanged
the queen ends up on F4 and suddenly the
Knight on F3 is a target to the capture
I did make a promise though I'm gonna
rewind really quickly just very very
quickly show why Bishop H7 fails right
after Knight G5 King G8 Queen H5 you say
oh it's Checkmate but no the Knight
drops into F6 at exactly the right
moment and H7 is fully protected so
I know people in the chat are you know
great gift sacrifice obsessed gotta keep
you accountable
yeah do it
I like this move
I I like arjun's position I I actually
think that he he's done exactly what he
needs to do he's played a solid opening
but an opening where he clearly
maintains winning chances this isn't
just a draw there's tons of pieces left
on the board
and it's just you know sufficiently
double-edged you couldn't ask for a
better outcome of the opening
yeah I know this is like the least
drawish equal that it could possibly
have that's a good way to put it
um but yeah once again Bishop C3 though
by rajabov I want to point out that you
know while we can highlight how great
Bishop F4 is I think Bishop C3 is also a
tremendous response and it's difficult
to sit there when an exchange is being
proposed and actually make the the right
choice and have that concrete
understanding that actually we don't
want to trade those pieces right now
Bishop C3 I'd rather defend the center
with the Bishops and actually lacks
Bishop on F4 is now on a square where
the queen wants to be so it's kind of
taking a square from maybe where where
the the queen wants to join to put
pressure on F3
yeah it's like the boss is kind of
looking at it's a a subordinate and
saying uh you need to get up from the
table I need to eat my dinner at this
seat yeah they're right there that's
where I sit right there I need the F4
score so you could play something like
Bishop to H6 but then I mean obviously
you're putting the bishop on an
incredibly awkward Square so you might
as well roll with it if you're black and
just keep the bishop here for the time
being uh if I'm margin I'm considering
moves like Knight D7 to F6 uh it maybe I
don't actually know it's not that easy
to find an improving move here for black
and the move E6 E5 always has to be
considered it's an incredibly committal
Pawn breakthrough and it needs to be
calculated
but my gut feeling is that it's still
premature here
um there is also an idea to combine
Bishop H6 perhaps with G6 not sure maybe
first or afterwards but
um as you're highlighting there to put
the bishop back on G7 and then we we
have nice pressure on D4 and I always
like these ideas that once you have the
bishop on G7 black has ideas of playing
Knight C5 and utilizing the the long
diagonal from h8 to A1 and the loose
Bishop on C3 so I kind of like the idea
of a bishop on G7
um so I would be thinking about G6
Bishop H6 for black the other thing is
how dangerous is the move that's just
been played A4 I mean white collude
wants to play A5 take that pawn maybe
utilize the open file for The Rook Rook
to A7 all of a sudden you're coming in
with threats like Bishop to E4
no that's a great point it's so easy to
take a move to not take a move like A4
seriously and ah you know it's just Pawn
pressure I can deal with that but then a
rook appears on A7 and you know that's
when the camera threats start wait maybe
I should have played A5 Arjun decides on
Queen to C8 is he considering
some sort of Bishop ba Queen C7 maneuver
that's pretty sick yeah that's the case
I think that is the planning you know it
also stops Rook A7 for whatever that's
yeah
really interesting
cool idea by Arjun so he did I think
think on similar lines with that Bishop
on it before he realized that it was
misplaced and rather than G7 its home is
going to be ba
okay now her job has to he has to deal
with that that will create serious
threats
you could also say the same thing while
it's easy to underappreciate or not take
A4 seriously I think it's also easy to
look at Queen C and be like ah whatever
you know I'll deal with that when it
happens and then it happens and you're
like wait a minute Bishop B8 Queen C7
suddenly Bishop takes F3 is a serious
move and if you go Pawn to G3 the bishop
on B7 just becomes a total monster on
that diagonal yeah hitting the Knight on
F3 which would become very loose and in
that case I think E5 uh would be far
more dangerous of a force to be reckoned
with for white so the fact that Timur is
spending a good chunk of time here I
think is a clear signal that he's he is
taking this should be a queen C7
seriously
and there's different ways to fight it I
mean you could try to push D5 at some
point I can't find a way to make it work
though that Queen on E2 is not only
misplaced but it's got to protect the
Knight you can't exactly play Queen C2
and a loud Bishop takes F3 that seems
Unthinkable to me so it's a hard
position to play for both sides in in
conclusion and I mean I'm kind of
fixated on Bishop ba Queen C7 I wanted
to ask you about the move A5 E5
is this is this an idea that black has
because if you get B5 and and you force
C5 that's really what you want then
suddenly the light square has been
really challenging in the middle so
strangely enough I think Queen C8 was
multi-purpose
yeah no this was such a deep move and
Bishop C3 to B2
might actually be you know among the
ideas of this move could be to prepare
A5 and take the sting out of B5 yep and
Arjun he's not rushing with Bishop E8 he
plays the move H6
kind of a waiting approach kind of
waiting to see
what concrete action Timur is going to
take and on which side of the board he's
going to take it
right I think each like once he's
decided and I believe he has removed
Queen C8 that that Bishop is retreating
maybe to B8 I don't think he's playing
Bishop H6 I don't think he's playing G6
Bishop G7 so if he's already decided
that then H6 does make sense
and there's a five by two more which is
also totally sensible I think you hit
the nail on the head I'm on Bishop B2
it's now clear that this was prophylaxis
against B5 maybe among other things
there's Bishop B8
so we've got we've got most of the ideas
down here but now it comes down to okay
uh whites executed their plan of you
know keeping pieces on the board and
getting rid of that weakness right
taking that pawn that was isolated on A2
suddenly we're trading it on B6 and if
black takes back with the pawn it's
actually black spawns that are just as
weak as whites oh totally now the pawn
on B6 is isolated and if you're a team
or maybe you take a totally positional
approach maybe you say okay I'm gonna
take I'm gonna go Rook ac1
um and maybe we should wait for him to
make a move but just I'll show this
really quickly Rook ac1 Queen C7 and
perhaps Bishop E4 is the way to take the
sting out of Black's battery because
Bishop takes F3 and queen H2 is the main
threat that black creates and with the
light squared Bishops gone yeah this is
annoying but the Knight on F3 is a very
robust defender of the H2 Square in a
position like this you could make the
case that white has a tiny Edge because
of the Pawn on V6 and guess what Rook
ac1 is indeed on the board
yeah and after Queen C7
I do want to point out it's possible
that after Queen C7 even if black had
two moves in a row you're not really
threatening to deliver mate with Bishop
takes Knight you know it's it's a check
um it's not the end of the world however
it still looks like something I don't
want to allow most people though I'm on
I think a lot of and Yoko signed this
point A lot of people are so afraid of
that shotgun they just kind of oh my God
it's mate yeah it's me King has an
escape Pathway to E2 so actually
checkmating the king in this way often
requires you to control the e-file and
with a pawn sitting on E6 that's not
very realistic mm-hmm
yep and uh I think the way that I think
rajabov has handled this game in a
really nice way uh he's just he's
handled everything that Arjun has thrown
at him whether it's been his Bishop F4
move Queen C8 move
um Bishop B8 I feel like every idea that
Arjun has had and he's been relatively
creative thus far he's had a cool answer
to and queen C7 is going to be met with
this cold shower Bishop E4 and
you just you're not getting anything
going on the king side you're not
significantly worse but you're just not
getting anything going and it felt like
Arjun was going to get something and be
a little bit more tricky than than what
he's got right now yeah and and it's so
tempting in such situations to just sink
a ton of time uh trying to you know
sharpen the position up again but I
think Arjun just has to come to terms
with the fact that this is going to be a
a relatively quiet position uh at least
in the near future as he puts his Bishop
back on F4 that's a big move what do you
make of that is he trying to go E5
um I think he's trying to offer a draw
after Rook A1 and Bishop B8 that's right
calling it here in the analysis box Rook
back to A1 Bishop back to B8 and both
players are happy with a draw
um but honestly Rook A1 first move that
I think of obviously there's been a
repetition so you know that Rook A1
can't be a bad move but also Rook C2 and
it does feel a little disconnected there
with your root they can't really double
easily and I I don't even think you want
the Rooks to be doubled you actually
want a rook on E1 you want a rook on C1
you want what you have
no you won't you have Rook C2 also I
think makes E5 a little bit more
tempting if we bring up an analysis
board here right uh the problem is that
White's back rank is now a little bit
more exposed so you could imagine for
example de5
uh also move like Knight C5 and guess
what that Rook on C2 is so awkward it's
preventing the Bishop from escaping back
toward this diagonal
I I think given the situation in the
match uh two more is just going to avoid
all of this like the plague and he's
gonna play Rook A1 or maybe Rook C to D1
is is the other candidate move
right and Rook C to D1
um I guess after that move it makes less
sense for black to go Bishop B8 right
it's like that then you're kind of like
trying too hard it's like
relax
not that easy well what is black gonna
do then after Rook cd1 I move like Queen
C7 or Knight F6
something like that I guess I think I
think there's the this there's
definitely something in this position
right now about these Knights that if
black plays Knight F6 I think white
plays Knight E5 and White's kind of
waiting for the Knight to move for black
in order to play that night move for
white now if the Knight stays on D7 I
suspect the Knight will stay on F3 but
as soon as it moves I think White's
looking to play 95.
yeah it's one of those cat and mouse
positions where essentially neither side
has any independent ideas of their own
they're basically just waiting to react
to their opponent's moves
and in the meantime they're trying to
make incremental improvements to their
position so the question is who has more
of these incremental improving moves and
I think right now the ball is in Black's
Court in that regard it's very very hard
for black to find one of those
um I've heard them refer to as small
little moves you know little improving
moves small moves exactly small moves
yep a little is the key one one uh I
guess not so small move is Bishop C6
with the idea of like Queen to B7 as a
follow-up so getting the queen behind
the bishop in a way where it's not Queen
A8 because that can always be challenged
Rook A1 but safe place for the Queen
Bishop but then we're threatening Bishop
takes the Knight on F3
um but move Rook C1 I think there's an
indication here that rajabov is fine
with a repetition this is where if
you're playing an over the board game
you accompany this move by looking up at
your opponent with the like leading eyes
and you kind of are moving your head
from side to side the universal kind of
symbol okay position balanced you know
let's call it a night you know get a
beer at the bar let's let's let's call
it a day please shall we yeah and it's
also um you know sometimes you're hoping
your opponent repeats like desperately
but even here I think your job off is
fine to keep playing as well like if he
knows the position is good here it's not
it's not a position where he's like
begging for repetition either so I yeah
I think he'd be happy with it but um if
Arjun wants to play on that's fine in
fact we saw that in the previous game
Daniel uh a draw could have been on the
board if uh Arjun had taken on pass on
right in the opening he said he wanted
to play okay rajaba is a professional
that's what he's here he's here to play
if white wants to make an early draw so
be it but you know if uh your opponent's
here to play I feel like he's not
he's not very far removed from the game
as soon as it's time to play again he's
just locked in oh totally totally and
this is this is decision time for our
generic icy you can just sense the
wheels turning in his head and he's
thinking okay I can take this draw then
I have a must win with white but I'm
playing freaking Timur a job of one of
the most solid super GMS I mean beating
him on demand is crazy hard so the
question for Arjun is does this position
offer you know significant winning
chances and I think given the time
situation he's now down a minute on the
clock the answer is probably no the
answer is probably you should go for the
draw get the white pieces you know take
a couple minutes to rest and and do your
best to try to force arm again but we'll
see nope
he goes for it I don't like that call
I'm gonna go out and say it on record I
don't love that call
I don't like to call either but I I
think that it's also a little bit to do
with who he's playing like I'll be the
first to admit that in my own games I
can get a little bit attached to a
repetition and then when my opponent
doesn't take it I I take that as a sign
of confidence that they're playing and
maybe I start to doubt my own position
and I just don't think that's the case
with rajaba he probably thinks the
opposite he sees night at six and he's
like ah my opponent wants to play on but
I think he's made a concession in order
to do so so he might view Knight F6 is
like okay you know all right uh Young
Gun we're gonna play are we well okay
you know you asked for it and this will
be a really interesting game I love the
you know the spirit from from origin to
play on oh for sure like the overall
decision but it does mean Daniel that we
are in for a much more exciting and
thorough game I no I'm definitely not
complaining and you know this is a brave
call by Arjun no question about it
I think the chess Gods will smile on him
uh in in a 50 50 situation and tumor is
now burning a lot of his own clock
trying to figure out how to continue
improving his position and there's
Bishop B1 a mirror image of arches
Bishop ba move and a mirror image in the
sense that the idea Iman I think is
exactly the same Queen C2 and Knight G4
there will be hell to pay if White's
Queen lands on H7
and you know hilarious to think that we
were talking about the queen being on H2
not a moment ago and now we're nearly
getting that Queen on H7 so both sides
having to deal with the the brunt of
these two Bishops B7 B8 B2 B1 they're
aimed straight at the opponent's king
and also I know we mentioned it before
Dania but how quickly did that Knight
end up on E5 as soon as Knight F6 was
played it was snapped immediate it was
like a group of high school kids when
when there's free donuts you know or in
college when they'd announce free donuts
in the in the dorm Lobby
you know that'd be gone before you even
finished reading the message that's how
quickly the night appeared on E5 but
Rook CA that's a good move that's a or I
thought it was a good move by Arjun
trying to put pressure on essentially
one of White's only targets right the C4
Pawn which is tender it's not a big
weakness but it is tender
and yet the eval bar seems to hate this
move
yeah it's like that's a good move it
makes a lot of sense I really like it
but it's actually a bad move and yeah we
will find out why yeah it's a mystery to
me it might be that Queen C2 uh isn't
actually prevented maybe rajaba should
stay the course and it's important to
point out him on that after Queen C2
Bishop takes E5 uh only accelerates uh
the defeat because now the Knight has to
move and you're getting the queen of H7
so
is on the board this is uh this is
really nice and you notice how White's
refraining from playing the move G3 as
well it's like tempting hit that Bishop
it's nearly trapped but the bishop will
capture on E5 and you know the I mean
queen C6 might be a follow-up getting on
that long diagonal yeah you can have
Queen C6 then perhaps so I can put a
Pawn on F3 you can Envision things
getting tactical here with both both
sides building the Queen Bishop battery
and then budding heads uh who's gonna
infiltrate first right what man Arjun
has to tread so carefully because Knight
G4 is also in play a similar idea to to
smoke this night out of out of F6 that
is the dream scenario for white uh-huh
yep be on the lookout for moves like D5
as well
um sometimes you can even just sack
these pawns because then your knight G4
move hits like a truck with the bishop
on B2 also joining
oh no that is like an ideal piece
configuration every piece doing its part
and Arjun continues to slip on the clock
is time is dwindling he's below four
minutes and Knight G4 is a force to be
reckoned with
man this is getting this is getting
very very tense for black these next
couple of moves are going to determine
the course of the game I think
absolutely because you can't all of a
sudden undo things you can't first of
all there's no draw on the board anymore
so it's like it's not it's not like oh
by the way
um and I'm actually surprised that the
move H5 hasn't like just broken the eval
bar yeah it's not just shot up
yeah it's let's say you know
oh H5 Force mate yeah Knight in Queen H7
Knight G6
but the idea is Crystal Clear he's
stopping Knight G4 it makes so much
sense I mean really obvious but the
movie H5 feels so loose right all of a
sudden that H Pawn is there and you
can't really I mean sometimes you could
play the move G6 but oh boy that move
looks scary to connect all the pawns
like that that pawnshell does not look
like it would withstand a magnitude like
1.5 earthquake but the other benefit of
H5 I'm on is that now after G3 okay
Bishop takes C5 might be okay but black
black can also dropped the bishop to H6
so this has created a little bit of Luft
for the bishop and it's getting Timur a
job off to it's been a long time that
Knight on F6 is suddenly Public Enemy
Number One for white and it's very hard
to smoke that Knight out of its shell
with Knight G4 no longer possible
yeah that's a really key resource that's
also just not available
yeah and after he takes D5 the Knight on
E5 simply hangs like you said Knight D7
uh you know you could get away with the
move like that but that's not see more
style and that does not look like a
recipe for success in a game where
you're perfectly satisfied with the draw
so I think what Timur is looking for is
a way to keep the status quo he waits
for me to say this and then D5 appears
on the board
gotcha
um I was thinking D5 if takes I actually
think we want to just take it back no
perhaps we unleash moves after that
whether it's like Knight G6 or really
night almost anywhere with the idea of
like getting rid of the the Knight on F6
with the bishop the D5 Bishop will be
loose and perhaps go from there so after
Ed if we if we bring up an analysis
where do you want to take back
that's what that was my first instinct
but do you do you have another move
oh I also thought this was the way to go
I thought that white could play rookie
five rookie 5 and D6 and win The Rook
back but this fails on several fronts
such as Queen C6 Queen C6 is some is the
best one yeah that's just the most
obvious to say hey nothing works for you
because meat on the board is happening
so so now I'm back to puzzled so you
have to defend the Knight and preferably
attack the bishop at the same time is
there a move that checks the boxes Queen
F5 maybe like yeah I mean I that's just
a that's a Great Cookie Cutter stencil
way to get me to find the move it's like
I need to attack the bishop and defend
my knight well you don't say Daniel yeah
perhaps and that is on the board Timur a
job of I mean he's so multifaceted now
right he's positional but what he's
showing in these last couple moves that
he's not just gonna shy away from
complications just because oh it's
tactical and I'm okay with the draw he's
going to play the position
right now Alexa is like ready to chime
in because I I think uh maybe uh you
know any any computer uh program these
days it's it's got a few chess uh lines
programmed in as well probably spots the
wind
yeah I should ask Alexa what team were a
job off should play in this position
Bishop H6 uh oh and now it's the eval
bar shooting up
well I mean take your pick Daniel
because at this point we can see the
ingredients right Queen on H7 is going
to be Checkmate Queen H7 Queen h8 mate
as long as you can just get rid of that
F6 Knight and a model six just doesn't
do anything I love C takes D5 that just
shows such restraint he's playing Knight
D7 he's not taking him F7 he's just
saying my position is so Superior
because of the way my pieces are placed
I don't need to rush I can recapture the
pawn and if black plays Bishop takes D5
then obviously Rook takes D5 and Quinn
H7 and 97 is game over Red Rover oh that
is and look how quickly he played it
right yeah he's just handing the ball
back to Arjun and saying I mean I don't
see a single move for you you could not
place any of white spaces better than
they currently are oh
no this is literally perfect peace
placement he needs a couple more moves
to finish this off you can see
the evaluation but it doesn't tell the
whole story this is the kind of plus
five that I could totally envision
turning you know I could see the tables
turning if white doesn't
for sure find a way to stick the queen
on H7 in the next couple of moves I can
see a few moves that I don't really have
answers to for black
um one of them that came to mind
honestly was like Knight C4 like a move
like that just as a yeah Knight C6
Knight C4 the more direct one that I
really want to calculate is Knight F7
that's that's the move that um
looks really frustrating for me Knight
C6 strikes me as the most natural uh
mostly because not only does the thread
in Bishop F6 but it also contains the
idea of Knight E7 in certain positions
right and he plays it but the evil bar
shoots back down
why okay yeah exactly why you know the
thing about Knight C6 that I I agree
with
um from what you were saying is that it
doesn't give anything up right no you're
not committing anything so if things
don't really work out the way that
you've been calculating you're not in
trouble afterwards whereas if you play
something like Knight F7 it's like hey
if that doesn't work you might lose this
game
yeah I mean I I have no idea what like
saving resources Arjun has 40 seconds if
he's able to save this game I will be
I will become an Arjun fan for life you
know like this is a Herculean task with
an hour on the clock let alone 36
seconds and King fade was not the way
no I I mean there's a an H7 yeah so
after that Queen h8 is the threat G5 oh
my God reminiscent of a resource
Carolina Mist and another one we were
commentating that is a crazy because you
only think of G6
yeah you only think of G6 that drops the
bishop because it severs the die between
the queen and the bishop but also
the the possibility of white putting the
bishop on that diagonal was dangerous so
Arjun gives away the exchange
in a last-ditch attempt
to explain half of the attack yeah you
have to give that up but you know
remember this isn't like a bullet game
where black has Chances with the two
Bishops this is like no you're just down
material
you're down in exchange the attack rage
is on you've got 20 seconds
foreign
it's never over till it's over it's
never over till the fat lady sings but
[Music]
um
come on this is this is looking real
Grim for Arjun
yeah because I mean
think you could maybe just go Knight C4
look at a kind of simple style move
um just to look to trade pieces mobilize
that d-pawn and if things trade it looks
like it does so favorably for white so
that's my first move that I know I have
um if I can't find anything better two
more plays and I think it's a very good
practical decision even though the
Eagles yeah maybe not the best maybe not
the clinical option but trade Queens
enjoy your life torture black for the
remainder of the game this is almost
reminiscent of the previous game where
hypothetically this blackout drawing
chances yes you have drawing Chances
with 20 seconds and white with the
possibility of torturing you for the
next 50 moves and not really
right so this is uh let's let's not
forget this is Arjun playing for his uh
you know his life in the tournament
right uh Glo in the global Championship
is a knockout so he he at this point
needs a draw to even put himself in a
position to need to win the next game
yeah it's not like he draws on anything
happens like he's still down a point
yeah your job of trying to trade a pair
of Bishops I think that is the next step
for white get rid of Black's Bishop pair
reduce the activity of Black's pieces
and some more just kind of bringing his
pieces back to home base you know
unwinding the Machinery it was like the
scene at the candidate tournament after
commentary finished you know powering
down the computers the attacks so we can
now enjoy our life
no I was gonna say takes on E3 Rook
takes D3 would be a cold shower there
does Arjun want to take now is that
reasonable I mean it's such a tough
choice my feeling is yes it does
especially given the time I have six
but could you do that right away You're
Gonna Lose the Jeep on or maybe oh yeah
Rook B8 Rook B7 I agree that's bad
there are drawing chances here that
night on E5 is a pretty darn good piece
can you set up some sort of a fortress
and can you do it with six seconds G5
okay F6 yeah F I think whoa
this is getting I I don't like G5 H4 for
black I I feel like that really helped
White's chances well that pawn is a
Sitting Duck isn't it yeah
I think Bishop D5 and Bishop F3 is the
simplest menu or this
just trade the Bishops
nah this is this is losing
I think you can trade I don't know I
wouldn't risk it if I'm too more I think
he will
look at the concentration on both of
these players faces says it all
if you're a job of I'm on the last thing
you want us to miss a fork Rook takes C5
I think that wins
oh that's such a six seconds calculating
it no he doesn't quite have it worked
out you know he wants to repeat once get
back to it
okay he's gone King G5 this is
completely winning you just have a pass
deep on you're pushing it yeah that has
to be enough unless he misses a fork the
game is over
agreed
it's always possible to miss a fork
always it's truly always like like
doesn't matter what position you have or
how good you are
getting F4 he's calculating can you take
it and G3
I think E5 is good enough yeah E5 God
that's such a gutsy that's so gutsy with
four seconds left
G3 G3 he needed G3 oh my God what a save
oh the match continues
H3 on the next move
on to H3 is a key move
holy smokes
about the exchange turns out to be the
downfall unreal
he could have ended the match right
there and you see rajabov the head shake
as he is now rewinding the clock in his
head and he just saw it that's the look
Daniel when it's like oh my goodness I
just needed to play Pawn to G3
that is unbelievable we need to bring up
I mean E6 is such a natural movie
thinking so I thought it was over after
E6 but H4 is a brilliant resource by
Arjun deflecting the king it turns out
I'm on when you push pawns and pawn end
games they become weaker and King F6
locks out whites King wins the pawn back
the move as you expertly called was
indeed G3 to prevent H4 Force black to
make a move and now come around H6
shouldering black skin out of the way
and reaching a winning Pawn end game
ladies and gentlemen what have we not
seen in the cgc now Timur a job up has
to gather himself mentally amazing and
Arjun aragaisi with the white pieces as
a new lease on life will he be able to
make it count will he Mount one of the
most shocking cgc comebacks of all time
or we'll team over a job off stay solid
and hold his own in the final game we
will see
you'll let the players take a breather
and we will take one ourselves you're
watching the chess.com Global
championship and we will be back with
the fourth and final match game of the
final matchup of 32 on the other side of
this short break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
open to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best we
are in for a wild ride and hey have we
mentioned there's also a million dollars
at stake the total pot is a million
dollars no that it's not a typo the
prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain he knows exactly what's
about to happen oh my goodness this is
over a heartbreaker for Mr svidler y'all
know probably if she pulls through once
again
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real oh gosh no time oh
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
thank you
as we look at the group E bracket the
only one remaining to be filled here at
the chess.com Global Championship we've
seen some crazy stuff in every bracket
but especially in this one an
unforgettable match between nepo and
Spindler and now I'm on and another epic
match to round off the bracket it seemed
all but decided for Jabba wins game two
he's winning game three a beautiful
positional game to outplay our generic
ice and then just when the death Metals
seem to be ringing the unthinkable
happened and Arjun saves
that's a perfect summary and another
reminder that I mean Daniel this is the
global Chess Championship right uh I
mean the point of this entire event is
unpredictability we can't get out of the
round at 32 without another match that
we have no idea what's gonna happen in
and it looked all too easy it was too
routine and I say the word routine
because that might be exactly the Trap
that rajabov fell into being too routine
in that end game conversion that's a
reminder that in chess you always have
to calculate to the very end of the line
nothing is as easy as it seems what a
resource by Eric icy who hangs on and
stays in the match by the skin of his
teeth but needs to win on demand here to
continue the Cinderella run
yeah I mean a lot of people would have
probably considered resigning in that
position it was demoralizing
debilitating he was getting crushed for
the last 25 moves and just to stay in
the game to have the alertness uh to
figure out that resource with his last
seconds is nothing short of amazing and
it is the reason why Arjun part of the
reason why he's had such impressive
growth his resilience is second to none
but you're right I'm on I mean the
what's the reward that you get for that
impossible save well now yeah you've got
the white pieces but you have to beat
Timur a job of on-demand one of the most
solid players of all time somebody who
did not lose wait did he lose a single
game with the candidates
I don't remember him losing no no I
think he
he might have but the fact remains he's
unbelievably solid and he's obviously
going to play
uh you know one of the more solid
openings in his repertoire we have a
Carlsbad variation of the Queen's gamma
declined on the board
this is interesting because I I um I
mean a lot of recent work I think has
been put into this opening
um at the top level so it's interesting
to see the developments but I actually
like the uh the opening overall by Arjun
as a try for a win
um I think it's a very double-edged
opening a lot of pieces remain on the
board it's not very easy to just trade
everything off unless you really try to
force this one concept of Knight to E4
for black so Knight to E4 and then
you're looking to treat dark Square
Bishops you're looking to maybe trade
the knight in the center but uh White's
plans usually revolve around the
unorthodox development night G to E2
this allows for the pawn to creep up to
F3 and potentially a central expansion
with E4 yeah this F3 E4 plan has has
really existed for many decades since
the time of
nick uh in in the 50s I think he was one
of the the pioneers of this system for
white previously White had been
automatically putting the Knight on F3
uh black for his part has a bunch of
possible ideas uh first of all E4 is not
the end of the world even if this move
is played it comes with a pretty hefty
price tag it weakens a lot of squares on
the king side in the center and scratch
everything because white has castled
Queen side and you certainly do not see
that every day in this line
no I you also don't see the you know the
requisite result of a win uh necessary
by the white players every day in this
line and I think that is the biggest
contributing factor to the move long
castle where the ideas remain the same
but we also have an additional plan of
G4 H4 and a king side attack
I think that might have even overtaken
uh E4 in terms of likelihood now for
timore he's got no time to waste you
have to Counter Strike on the queen side
and typically in such positions you have
two ways of doing you can take the
standard approach with a pawn storm or
you can try to open files with a timely
c65 although that's an incredibly risky
move because it weakens the D5 Pawn
severely
right and although there's been a
commitment to the queen side here white
can pivot and just play a positional
game as well if you play C5 hang on the
rook's already on D1 it's like perfect
to attack that D5 Pawn so white hasn't
done anything too crazy yet that
indicates black can just you know
sacrifice all positional understanding
um that he has and just go all out here
I think white can just play King to B1
and still play this game in reasonable
fashion I don't think that's what he's
gonna do but it was available this is an
old school opposite side castling like
B5 G4 kind of game uh where neither side
is trying to be creative both sides are
just trying to go for their opponent's
throat though logistical difficulty
though I'm on in terms of Black's attack
is that if you play B4 prematurely the
knight's gonna stick itself on A4 you
could even play B3 and it's gonna take
you know a thousand pounds of weight to
you know to to to break through the
defenses so if you're a job you have to
be very strategic about exactly how you
storm the queen side with your pawns
maybe you start with A5 and A4 instead
of rushing with B4
yeah and also uh the move Knight E6 well
it looks so natural it actually does
drop a pawn bishop takes the Knight on
F6 and Bishop takes on H7 96 looks so
easy to play you want to get that Knight
in the game gain time attacking the
bishop maybe support C5 but you can't
really do that also the move 94 that I
mentioned earlier isn't available to
maybe get some trades in so black is
left with a situation where there's no
easy moves to make there's no like you
know vacuuming all the pieces off the
board I don't think you want to play the
move Pawn to H6 that just looks like a
Target so he's gonna have to be creative
and play some other moves Queen A5 on
the board are we looking at B4 Bishop A6
kind of stuff
yeah possibly maybe B4 and C5 he's
trying to sneak in
uh but but the fact remains uh B4 can be
met with Knight A4 and and that is a
pretty major worry uh to me in in
regards to Black's uh the prospects of
of a successful attack on the queen side
how is black going to solve the problem
of the White Knight appearing on A4 in
response to B4
yeah and you know with the queen on A5
as well any thoughts upon A5 pontev or
first out of the window that's no longer
possible
um I'm also really looking at the move
King B1 I I'm attached to this move I
really like it white can also continue
Knight B1 uh sorry Knight C1 to B3 after
that
um if you need an extra Defender there
or as I've been saying you can kind of
pivot and play a little bit more
positional as well against the C5 square
and the C6 weakness
yeah it should be pointed out just like
in the first game that you're not
signing a contract that demands that you
have to play H4 with white and you you
must make only attacking moves you
haven't sacrificed anything
your King on C1 is not as far from safe
but it's also far from being imminently
checkmated so moves like King B1 are
hard to play for a lot of players who
start to get anxious in these situations
and feel like every Temple's golden I
have to push my pawns that's not how you
attack at a high level at a high level
you combine positional moves and
tactical moves and attacking moves and
defending moves and the player who finds
the right combination of all those types
of moves ultimately prevails
that was uh that was really well said I
liked it was almost like you dropped a
riddle for us there I I am far from safe
but I'm far from danger where am I
actually you're a king on C1 yeah this
is exactly what you are yeah I moved to
B1 to become safer
and H4 speak I mean obviously I wasn't
trying to suggest that you know we're
not gonna see H4 I just
you know it was a matter of time and
it's not forced but a pawn does appear
on H4 and there's another question to be
asked where is White going with his
attack because like even if you play H5
and H6 well I can respond with G6 so I'm
on the black king surrounded as it is by
a defensive cocoon is also not easy to
approach
it's not I
um I love the way that white has done
things so far I think that the move
before for me has a really natural
reaction of Knight A4
um so I I'm really comfortable here with
white pieces because again g4h4 you
haven't done anything too crazy just yet
over there and I I still see just
positional glaring weaknesses over jabov
and I'm not sure how he's going to
continue with that pawn there like you
want to sacrifice it maybe get a rook to
see it I'm not even sure you're gonna
get that far nope and I think B4 might
have been a bit of a panicky panicky
kind of move by two more he also has to
avoid falling into the cycle of thinking
hey why am I in this situation to begin
with like all I had to do was make one
move and I'd be enjoying you know a
glass of champagne right now getting
interviewed and I'd be in the round of
16. once you start getting into those
negative thought cycles that interferes
with your thinking and even the top
players are not immune from it but C5 is
indeed on the board
okay well I that's that's an amazing uh
amazing move there because first of all
I mean now that I see this I'm looking
in hindsight and saying um okay it'd be
nice to have my king on B1 burning the
A2 Pawn you know Knight takes C5 right
now I believe that's the intention Queen
takes A2 question is I mean is that
really anything to be too scared of
no I I don't think black should hang his
hat on the fact that he's taken A2
because White's King as in the previous
game right we were talking about Queen
H7 or queen H2 not being as lethal as it
appears I think we've got a similar
situation here white can escape to D2 on
demand maybe he should do it now
or maybe you should start with a more
solidifying move like I don't know Queen
B3 maybe Knight F4 there's a lot of
candidate moves here I was looking at I
don't think it's quite there yet but I
was looking at some funny ways to try to
trap the queen like Bishop B5 and Knight
B3 and it's like oh yeah you know you're
kind of uh somehow managing to trap the
queen there but King D2 obviously with
the same intent and the hilarious thing
about this position is of course the
queen being trapped you're probably
going back Queen A5 and then if white
plays uh some of the moves you're
suggesting Rook A1 the queen goes back
even more and White's King has now got
back to the middle of the board the
rook's gone back to the square on A1
where it started yeah and it's almost
like you're undoing everything but
somehow your position has improved yeah
if you play King E1 then you have fully
uncastled
and that pawn on F3 is really I think
incredibly important because it's
restricting the Knight it's also
restricting the bishop by protecting G4
and by protecting the E4 Square it's
ensuring the long-term safety of white
skin no question that Black's attack has
backfired uh can Timur find a way to
first of all evacuate his Queen that's
the first order of business but then
find some way to whip up play against
whites King in the center
so if you want to bring up an analysis
board we can put a sample line of you
know how things might proceed uh I think
after King D2 Queen A5 and then Rook A1
and then if Queen C7
uh you know Knight A6 just as an example
okay and if the Queens trade in this
position because it looks like they're
kind of forced to this is back to what I
was saying before is that all of a
sudden you realize white has never had
this prerequisite to like attack or
Checkmate in this position white is
dominating positionally and you'll be
totally fine to play this position as
he's got full domination your B4 is
hanging C7 is loose I mean every piece
for white is so well placed and this is
just a disaster forward Java yeah and
just showing how you could end up losing
the b-pawn and then probably also losing
the d-pawn I think your point is
incredibly well taken it's so important
to realize that white hasn't actually
made any commitments and by the way Rook
A1 was played and precisely because of
Knight A6 Timur drops the queen not on
C7 but on B6 and I think his top
priority is probably to try to get rid
of this Knight maybe throw in 96 even at
the cost of a pawn I think you're that
desperate
I think it's uh it's in that territory
here
um as we see the move Rook H to C1
everybody's swinging to the other side
now
yeah it's all about the queen side and
little little would you know five moves
ago that it'd be it would be white
putting pressure on the queen side and
maybe black will start playing on the
king side before you know it attacking
these pawns yeah exactly a queen V8
Queen H2
exactly H6 there it is
see black is no longer afraid of making
a this move would be Unthinkable just
five moves ago white would take on F6
and go G5 and check me out now the
rook's no longer an H1
what a weird weird game as yeah he's not
interested in giving up the bishop for
no reason as the bishop to take back on
F6 I see a hilarious line of mine
what do you got Knight takes C6 if you
play Bishop takes e66 Bishop C7 Queen B7
Bishop P6 the queen is trapped that's
just that's ludicrous yeah
what a pretty trap I could I could see
somebody blundering that because you
could be so fixated on the night on E6
you think your Queen's out of the woods
but yeah you know just when because
that's probably why you played the move
H6 to get the pawn off H7 so it wasn't
wouldn't be hanging so he could finally
play this move 96 and free so it's been
played it's on the board do not tell me
he's gonna take back with a bishop but
the thing is the other move first of all
it's got to be the queen then right
because it has to be the queen but
that's the pawn takes it's the same
thing the podics it is the same thing oh
but if Queen takes here's the thing
white could even play the worst case
Queen C6
and I think it's just an overwhelming
end game uh for what
oh it's a terrible end game weak Pawn on
D5 Total Domination on the queen side
you know those Queen side pawns have
bitten off more than they can chew
I think Arjun
will take on E6 and he will pray
for a quick end to this game I've never
first of all I mean the match overall is
quite something but this specific
opening I don't think I've ever seen it
Go in this direction where you lose the
A2 Pawn vacate the king to the middle of
the board I've seen a lot of games in
the Carlsbad structure I've never seen
this well you know like five it's like
those statistics like five percent of X
gets into Y and then you know two
percent of that and one percent of that
uh you know like maybe five to ten
percent of Carlsbad games even feature
Queen side castling White Castle's King
side in the vast majority of games and
of the games were White Castle's Queen
side as you're saying the situation
where white ends up being the one who
attacks on the queen side himself is
exceedingly rare but that's why I love
chess like this is how rich the game is
like we've seen so many Carlsbad games
and even within this well-studied
structure you could basically have a
completely new game structure why is he
not taking on E6 yet
I really don't know so the other because
I don't like losing the darks were
Bishop Knight takes F4 like in general
if that happens I'm not feeling great
about it
um the only other moves to consider are
Night Moves it seems like in the other
direction I'd a four and at A6 but hmm I
just don't like giving away that that F4
Bishop so I'm really only considering
stuff like Knight A4 here
yeah Knight A4 I guess you're forcing
the queen to move back maybe to d8
right but then somehow it feels like
white needs to cash in this night and
Knight takes E6 is a great way to cash
it in because you're forcing black to
recapture awkwardly and you're opening
up the C file which is ultimately
you know the main artery which white is
going to access Black's position
yeah the thing about Knight takes Knight
is that if I look at all blacks pieces
the most annoying one is the Knight on
E6 by a landslide so I'm actually
getting rid of one of my opponent's best
pieces in doing oh you missed it oh my
God he plundered it but it's on the
board
unbelievable Bishop C7 wins the game now
after Bishop C7 I'm on black does have
the move B3 but that leads to a
completely hopeless end game
Bishop C7 B3 you take on B6 you take on
A7 and Blacken resign because he's
dropping two pawns it's on the board I
can't believe that that's I mean I think
great job off is so rattled from this
mistake in the in the previous game the
match should be over I feel like
everyone at the table right now knows
that but
Arjun is in you know he he has that
knowledge and he's using it to his
Advantage he's using it to fuel him in
this game rajaba I think it's he's
thinking about it and it's hurting his
calculation his decision making yeah and
this has been a sloppy game from from
his perspective he he just won't be
happy with how this position has gone
it's been you start to finish a great
chance for Arjun with the white pieces
to get a win on demand and the way he's
executed it is has a brilliant so far no
taking nothing away from Arjun the guy
is a beast the way he resisted last game
the way he's played this game is he's
played it like a professional he's
played like Magnus Carlsen it's just
like winning on demand in 23 moves but
at the same time I think you're
absolutely right this was an unrejab of
like game with like he just doesn't lose
games like this in 20 moves he doesn't
make blunders like Bishop C7 the way he
was attacking on the queen side I'm on
it seemed that he played B4 and then he
started thinking after Knight A4 rattled
I think is the best way to describe the
way that we see teamwork Jabba playing
in this game and this is a totally
residable position
it is
um I I certainly don't believe that it
will be no design
especially after what we just saw last
game you you definitely play out your
moments here
um and yeah you can you can take this
pawn and Knight C3 is also available but
I believe King takes C2 and you know
King D1 or King B3 even are just fine
could a case be made that after King
takes C2 black ones Bishop D7 the only
chance might be to
you know attack the tender Pawn on E3
yeah I like that I like that
no I think Knight C3 is even more
clinical to keep the king
in contact with the E3 pawn and then you
can pick up the C2 but I'm pretty sure
this Pawn's a Sitting Duck I don't know
I'm on maybe it's a strength but
something tells me where Jabba won't be
able to hold on to it
yeah the thing is I I I'm willing to bet
that King takes C2 Bishop D7 something
like Bishop C5 might just be like a very
like expedited way to trade things and
even at the cost of the E3 Pawn white is
just gonna then play King D2 and have
the B2 Pawn the C5 Pawn they're gonna
join with the move B4 and two connected
pass pawns rolling down the boards just
like so tough to deal with no it's it's
also completely winning I agree
or a job of instead trying to hunt for
this bishop on A7 the problem is that
after King G1
Rook takes C1 Knight takes C1 black is
no way of actually attacking this bishop
and on the next move White's going to
ensure that The Rook is defended so that
the bishop could move back to C5 and
once all of that happens then we could
start talking about resignation
and you know the pawns are just arranged
so perfectly on the king side as well
what why is that necessary
I mean
honest I gotta be honest I I understand
it in a way that like Rook takes Rook
takes everybody takes on C5 white plays
King like D2 let's say a knight jumps to
D4 and you've got this d-pawn that just
rolls and and none of Black's pieces
have any play after that so in that
sense I understand it but the problem is
that the alternative was so solid so
this is something I would land on if the
other lines were a little bit murky and
like maybe not so sure
um and I think Arjun might have missed
this move I I agree that this move might
have come as a surprise to him as he
would be expecting Bishop takes bishop
and I think White's Advantage is very
very real there
and I I'm influenced by the eval bar I
admit it you know guilty is charged but
it's just the question of like why are
you giving up pawns unnecessarily there
was really no need to do that you still
had a past b-pawn in the other line yeah
maybe he was worried about the pin along
the a file
he's definitely missed the move Knight
D7 and the idea of this move is to keep
the bishop to keep the dark short Bishop
Alive Black wants to take twice on C5
and suddenly the E3 Pawn is going to be
a major Target in the absence of White's
dark squared Bishop black has
you know legitimate chances
for the you know which is totally
Unthinkable reality given what we saw
three moves ago yeah this should never
should never have been the case uh
Bishop F5 might even be a further step
in the wrong direction when it rains it
pours
um again I understand a little bit why
you did this but I have no justification
for this move when the alternatives are
so solid so sound right that there there
were other moves King D1 where you
couldn't even find you couldn't even
find a single reason why why that that
shouldn't be played there was nothing
wrong with it at all very strange and
and you know what else uh is disturbing
is that from a psychological perspective
rajaba was kind of dead in the water he
was tilted you know he'd blundered he
was broken mentally and all of a sudden
you give the guy a bone right now I can
guarantee you Timur is thinking oh my
goodness like what did my opponent just
do I've got a serious chance to draw
this game and end the match and he's
feeling hopeful he's excited perhaps
perhaps about his prospects for the
first time this game even though
objectively he's still getting tortured
and he's still going to be miserable
evaluationally speaking but
psychologically speaking he's very much
back into it no it's uh I mean there's a
whole psychology to chess there's a game
on the board and there's a game off the
board and I think right now uh rajabov
is probably feeling as empowered as
Arjun was feeling at the beginning of
this game fresh off the blunder from
rajaba in that previous game you know
breathing new life into uh into this
match was Arjun and now reading new life
into this game is rajaba who finally
probably likes his position for the
first time all game and I I don't see an
adequate response to the move Rook B8
off the top of my head the issue is that
both of these pawns I've highlighted are
now yeah the B2 Pawn is White's main
asset but it's also one of White's main
weaknesses it is an isolated Pawn
uh and the king is currently occupied
defending E3 so what is white going to
defend the B2 Pawn with in the event of
Rook B8 is my question
yeah I think I want to go Rook B1 and
Rook B3 Knight C3 that's the best that
I've got right now
um so you know if you bring that Rook
down try to clamp the B2 Pawn
then I want to sit there with Knight C3
and and protect it so you want to go
here and in the event of a check you
block it this G4 is so important
defending the bishop but I should point
out him on but this trade is not
necessarily in Black's favor even though
it optically ruins white structure the
D5 Pawn is now not sitting pretty so
keeping the bishop on E6
is integral I think to Black's defensive
effort Rook B8 is indeed on the board
yeah I wonder here because uh I guess
there
is there a way to so first of all if the
Rook takes on B2 and white goes Rook A8
I was wondering how trustworthy that
position is for black having to play
Bishop f8 but it it looks like it's okay
looks like black is surviving there
although with the Knight coming to like
D4 or F4 and putting pressure on the
other Bishop it could potentially be
very disturbing
okay Rook C1
C3
and Bishop E7 I mean it does make a
threat of the H4 Pawn but I'm not not
necessarily sure that's a pawn that
White's gonna be like betting over
backwards to defend
probably not especially if you can find
a way to solve permanently solve the
problem of the b-pawn
I think Bishop B7 is Black's best chance
though I think you have to try to you
know breathe some uncertainty uh in into
arjun's mind you got to make him start
believing that he's screwing this up
which of course he is
um a very difficult task to make someone
believe that they're doing what they're
doing
um but the thing in chess is like even
though he's messed it up from a much
bigger Advantage he's still got an
advantage and objectively if he had
gotten to this position if Arjun had
arrived here with a slow you know
methodical advancing and improving of
the initiative he'd be feeling great
like wow this is a masterpiece I'm
really crushing my opponent and the
momentum the psychological game would be
in a totally different state but because
he got here from what should have been
probably game over flat out it probably
feels like he's messed this up and his
position is almost not as good as it
really is I I remember when I finished
my last John game at the under 14 World
youth Chess Championship I was really
really proud of it it was one of those
like long positional efforts I thought I
just played a brilliant game I come out
and my coach says you know Daniel if I
were to show two diagrams after move 20
and after move 50 one would think this
was the most brilliant game you know the
improvements that you made but if you
actually look at those 30 moves there's
basically nothing but mistakes uh you
know even though the end product looked
impressive so right it kind of reminds
me and of course I was upset H5 in the
meantime by Arjun I think a lot of
people are you know making a WTF phase
Rook takes B2 what is this idea is it to
play check and back to C7
yeah I think Jack might even yield like
Bishop f8 because of potentially how
annoying Rook C7 looks but you know
Bishop FH is one of these permanent
positions wait black can't do anything
yeah you can't defend D5 and if you just
go hunting for the H Pawn then this is
going to kill you at the end of the day
and if black doesn't play Bishop f8 if
black plays King H7 then the F7 Pawn is
a serious weakness but you could also
get checkmated from C7 Bishops before
and Rook to two is mate so it's not the
end of the game here it's actually a lot
more double-edged than it appears
no that's a really good point
um
this is so so uh compelling that black
didn't even take the pun he said Bishop
F6 first let me put more pressure so I
have an option I can take it with the
bishop or the Rogue the painting well I
can take it now blacken also played the
move d4
to you know damage white structure and
then take on B2
you have to weigh the pros and cons of
that or job of
instead I think he is trying to set up
D4
I think he's that's exactly what he's
trying to do with the Rook d8 he's not
just trying to defend passively right
right
it's clear he's got an active idea but
could white play something like Knight
A4
to meet D4 with E4
yeah I think the worst part about
White's position right now is that D4 is
a threat because of the Knight and if
the Knight wasn't there we wouldn't be
concerned about the move d4 probably at
all so I like the idea of movie tonight
and then if you do the the B2 Pawn would
be hanging so wow what a decision to go
for this he's decided to say look I'm
keeping my b-pawn you had your
opportunity twice with two different
pieces maybe to take it you haven't done
so now you know I'm going to show you
what what it's really worth
I also wouldn't be too dismissive of
White's Pawn structure yes it's you know
visually terrible and I'm not you know
exactly a staunch defender of the F5
Pawn but it is clamping down on Black's
own pawns right these F5 and H5 pawns
are preventing black from creating more
breathing room for his King you know the
F7 Pawn could be a long-term weakness of
flax King tries to hide away on H7 so
the situation on the king side is a
little bit more double-edged than it
seems but the bigger question is can
black
you know permanently restrain the
progress of the beep on
and again now our job of is on the
defending side of the kind of end game
uh that that Arjun had in game two where
you've got a minute 30 and white white
can torture and squeeze this forever
yeah all the pawns on light squares R
square Bishop on D4 yes you know no
Authority on that side of the board I
would have put the Rook on B1 almost
immediately but
I was wondering was he bothered At All
by Rook B5 and like kind of take a whole
bunch of Pawns because there's one idea
for black which is I can get my hand on
the majority of the king side pawns hey
I'll sack my Bishop
even if you just get one of the pawns
you should already consider a bishop
sack is those types of positions can be
fortresses especially with weakness
weakness on H5
Rook B5 I think is on tap and it's on
deck if white allows it
yeah Bishop G1 is a nice move like the
diagonal that the bishop wants to be on
is so long A7 and G1 you can't really
controls
it's like geez this is like you know New
York City to San Francisco like you got
to control vast territory and I think
Rook B5 Arjun
yeah or maybe 58 and Rook D5
that would be uh that would be a thing
that's a mess honestly because I might
have Rook B5 he wants Knight C5 I think
our general has forgotten that their
Rook can circumvent the knights
defensive power and he doesn't see it I
was gonna ask you what you thought about
Rook B5 Knight C5 Rook takes B4 Fortress
wise oh is that is that anything to to
ask about like Bishop versus Rook but
the pawns are all cemented like this my
gut is that that's losing because there
I actually would like the placement of
the pawns the fact that they're on light
squares and holding black spawns back I
think would be an asset F6 liquidating
one of his weak Pawns
it's
also uh liberating for black in a way as
well well with every Pawn that
disappears black gets inches closer to
the drug don't miss a fork on D7
yep
yep that's key here Rook G4 no that
doesn't work oh Knight D7 on Rook G4
97 and Rook G4 that is exactly exactly
what our dear silicon friend is looking
for
to point out is that that doesn't win a
bishop the problem is that you
transition to a rook end game where
Black's King is going to be on the H
file
yep and tomorrow Jabba fails
to hold the position I think Rook G4 is
still winning although it's a little
that's a much better move that's a way
better move than Rook d8 I think oh
totally totally really like that
we could get I'm getting vibes from the
previous game where you can get like a
knight versus Bishop position or droppa
finds some way to trade the last Pawn
yeah one Pawn at the end because here's
the thing look at the Knight on D7 and
look at the pawn advancing imagine the
Rooks are off the board not that hard to
do because they're about to be traded uh
the pawn from B4 only has two squares so
the bishop can sack B6 and V8 and both
those screws are covered by White's
Knight so you might think the game is
just over and you'd be correct if he
finds exactly how to do it so really
what we what we've got is very similar
as you said to the last game it could
come down to a single move oh and what
an amazing move by Arjun he's so patient
I think what he's saying is hey this
Pawn I can move it in five years from
now right now the top priority is to
save the age Pawn to eliminate the risk
of a fluke and then later when you get
the king to G4 you'll bring the Knight
back and guide the pawn to promotion G4
by rajabov a last ditch attempt to trade
as many pawns as possible
right what a move
and I think you can just take and play
night well almost anywhere I was gonna
say anywhere now you have the H Pawn and
you have the b-pawn keep in mind
sometimes if all these pawns are off the
board you don't even need anything on
the king side sometimes you just win
with the beep on and the Knight blocks
that Bishop from sacrificing
that's a great way to put it you could
do that from C5
last breaths here taken by Timur but now
he can no longer stop the age one it is
over and Arjun Eric icy is gonna win on
demand unbelievable this was not the
smoothest conversion but all credit to
Arjun I mean to do what he just did
against a player of rajaba's caliber
and he takes a deep breath I think Arjun
can't even believe what has just
happened he has set himself up for an
Armageddon game which he has a realistic
chance among of pulling off I'm not
exaggerating perhaps the greatest
comeback in the cgc inaugural season
thus far yeah there's no way that this
isn't the biggest because
sure the score might not look that bad
it's like oh it was only two to one you
came back a game you won Armageddon
great this isn't like a 2-0 comeback you
have to think about how the match could
have been over in one single move a move
that is probably replaying you know at
two times speed in the chat Bob's head
right now uh and G3 exactly G3 G3 our
generic icy stayed in that game he never
quite gave up on it even when some of
his fans might have been thinking oh
this is it he's out of the tournament
he's very much still in this event and
is now tied and we have Armageddon
coming up Daniel we do indeed we're
gonna set the players up we will get
their bids and we will talk and remind
you of the Armageddon format on the
other side of the break but ladies and
gentlemen go absolutely nowhere we have
one of the most exciting armageddon's in
a long time coming up for you here at
the chess.com Global championship and we
will set the players up and have the
Armageddon for you in just a couple of
minutes stay tuned
foreign
we are back at the chess.com Global
Championship as we have a look at the
bracket of the round of 16 we have one
more match that is ongoing to determine
the final 16. it is an epic match indeed
it is the match we are currently
watching between tomorrow Jabba and
Arjun aragaisi in that match
it's currently tied two two it will
round off the group E bracket
oh my goodness grab Mastermind Hamilton
I mean what haven't we seen in the cgc
that's why I mean we've seen literally
everything
and I was gonna say we haven't seen one
of the greatest comebacks but I forgot
that of course the router 32 is not over
yet it wouldn't repeat that and and
naturally they saved the best for last
in terms of entertainment now of course
it would be you know a huge huge uh
story if our generic guys see were to
come back and win this Armageddon thus
winning the match and the regret that
would sink in over job of having missed
the opportunity to close this out would
be immense but having said that Dania I
mean rajaba I feel like now he's had
time to cool down a little bit and this
is truly a different match and we've
always known rajaba to be a professional
I think this is where he can show that
this is absolutely where he can show
that we remind you of the Armageddon
format both players bid uh up to 15
minutes the side with the higher bid
gets white with 15 minutes the side with
the lower bid gets the black pieces with
the amount of time that they bid of
course black has draw odds which means
if the game ends in a draw and black
wins the match the bids are timora
jawbox 14 minutes clearly I wonder which
side he wanted to play and Arjun bidding
12 minutes and 30 seconds so Jabba will
have 15 minutes Arjun will have the
black pieces with 12 and a half minutes
that's a pretty generous amount of time
we saw Vichy beating bidding seven
minutes we've seen players bidding 11.
12 and a half is a boatload of time I
think this is a good start already for
Arjun
yeah indeed but you know from rajabov's
perspective he's also saying
he's basically saying I don't even want
to play with the black pieces or at all
yeah like he he's just like okay I'm in
a bid 14 minutes because if you for some
reason don't even want uh you know that
that much time then okay fine I'll take
it but he really wanted to uh to play
with the white pieces here and uh
perhaps that's because he feels good
about whether it's preparation he feels
good about the games have gone thus far
there have been some very combative
games and although we've had some draws
I feel like playing with the white
pieces makes a lot of sense and hey he's
up against 12 and a half minutes from
from Arjun so a bit of a Time Edge to
play into things and he's got another
rogozin repeating the opening from the
first game
I think it's reasonable to assume that
Arjun looked up the G4 shenanigans
and timurajaba varying his choice
putting the bishop on F4 this is a line
which just a couple of moves a couple of
years ago was very rare but has become a
lot more popular as people have shifted
away from the main lines in a lot of
openings and have tried to get fresher
you know more unexplored positions Rook
is on C1 already
you know just a sort of normal
positional line I don't think it's hard
to make any
qualitative observations here just a
line
yeah you know just developing pieces
yeah I mean I don't think white needs to
do anything spectacular here in order to
exactly like you don't need to go crazy
with moves like that A3 in fact he's
he's well because the rook's on C1 he's
absolutely gonna take back Rook takes C3
and you can kind of forecast White
smooth you might need to retreat that
Rook C7 is currently attacked E3 Bishop
E2 H3 castles you know easy I wonder I
wonder where you've played those moves
before E3 Bishop E2 and H3 hmm what kind
of system features those moves later I
just I thought of them right now for the
first time ever came up with them at the
board
um very unfamiliar territory to me
I mean
I actually like this Choice by our job
of I think one thing that
factors into his decision making is the
fact that this is likely Iman to lead to
a long positional game right the
structure is pretty closed you know
you're gonna get a long maneuvering
middle game and that is exactly what you
want to go to more uh given your time
advantage and given the fact that you
want this game to extend you want a 60
70 move Affair your reminder there is no
increment in the armageddonus good of a
bullet player as Arjun is if you're down
five minutes in a middle game with no
increment you know the clock basically
becomes another piece and Rook on B3
quite a piece that is you don't see that
every day in the opening
what the heck is that move I mean I
don't think you play Rook B3 unless
you've seen Rook B3 you know and unless
you've seen you know some analysis
you've done some games where it's like
okay yeah sometimes it goes there uh
otherwise I mean the Mover B3 just looks
strange at first glance one thing that I
did want to point out is that if you
brought the Rook back to C1 there there
is this idea of you know and I mean it
still exists Queen A5 yep um and you
know you can Mass trade everything I'm
not sure if that's what you want to do
but Knight D2 you could trade everything
on D2 go to an end game two Bishops for
white will speak volumes there but still
I know there is an idea that more pieces
you trade and solid structure like this
the closer you get to that draw which is
all origin needs to win this match
indeed and interestingly Timur didn't
even seriously contemplate taking the
pawn on B7 I think the evil bar did
seriously contemplate it uh but
understandable her job of doesn't want
unnecessary tactical complications
especially given the way the last two
games have gone C5 by Arjun I think
arjun's really the one uh trying to uh
instill trying to install tension on the
board but C5 from a positional
standpoint is an incredibly risky move
because if white consolidates black
could very well be left with a weak uh
isolated Queen Pawn add on to that
White's Bishop pair and you could be
talking about a serious positional
Advantage so black really has to try to
go after White's on castled King maybe
go after the awkward Rook to compensate
for the positional disadvantages do you
agree with that assessment
no all wrong
no that was uh that was really well said
um the other thing that you can point
out is that C5 the Knight jumps in and
The Rook it's feeling a little weird you
might see this Rook go on a real journey
this game Daniel like Rook B3 Rook
before yeah exactly no it could it could
get like a almost like a game of snake
or something
so what does timora Jabba's deciding
between well castles is obviously a
Canada move
do you take C5 and Rook takes B7 I think
are the three big candidate moves and
the benefit of a move like C5 from Arjun
is that see more has to spend time on
this decision he can't just move
instantly this is a big moment and and
he's got to try to prosecute this
position uh carefully and accurately
because this is a chance for him to get
an advantage he chooses the calmest of
the three moves castles
and could The Rook get trapped here I
don't know Rook takes B7
okay so Rook be set first of all Rook B7
is it forced
what is arjun's idea because I think a
lot of people might be saying oh Queen
C8 traps The Rook it doesn't even come
close to trapping the Rick because the
Rook has
a perfectly good parking spot on C7
black wax the dark squared Bishop so
getting C7 under control is gonna be
hard
okay that's good I mean it traps The
Rook but it's so long term right like H3
keep that bishop and then you've always
got C7
it's like those Norwegian or Finnish
prisons or you know you've got high
speed internet connection and you know
you've got your own personal library and
a nice desk it's like yes
accommodations on B7 exactly
but of course serious very
nerve-wracking
it is nerve-wracking I think the one
thing about the if you if you think
about what result is required for white
you are more interested in complications
in general so if you're offered a pawn
but you might get trapped you're gonna
take it because yeah you know if you
don't see it immediately and at least
you might have some compensation even if
it does get trapped I think you're going
for it versus you know shying away and
and playing uh something that just
doesn't have as much in it
now that's that's very well put I think
the move 95 appealed to me initially
when I looked at the position of course
that does close off the bishop and it
makes Queen C8 a more realistic
possibility but I was trying to figure
out
how to evaluate 95 Queen C8 Rook E7 and
if you try to keep pursuing the rook and
say oh three time repetition no no no
white has Knight C6 with a crushing
initiative Rook C7 and Knight E7 and
talk about the Rook uh taking a joyride
like that's exactly what you have here
and talking about my job off agreeing
with you Knight E5 very very fun looking
move and it's like how can white use the
squares in Black's Camp better than
black right how how is white using E7
and C7 and B7 and C6 I thought this was
Black's position
the the positive thing for Arjun is that
he's actually up on time you would never
guess that this is an Armageddon game
uh but the negative is I think that he's
just worse he's down a pawn I don't see
a way
to continue pursuing the E7 Rook
effectively
I mean maybe F6 to chase the Knight away
I don't know
F6 and Knight upstairs
actually actually
yeah it would be pretty serious idea I
think Bishop D6 there oh no Bishop D6
there's a 994. yeah so wait up how does
what does white do
what do you mean what is white dude
Daniel this is your brilliant line of
you all right you got us into this mess
to begin with and now you're asking what
to do so if we pull up an announcement
just to show where what the danger is F6
if you just play normally Knight F3 G5
Bishop G3 black enforcer repetition
takes takes and forget about Bishop C8 I
just like you can't see it exactly
yep draw your way to Victory Arjun has
decided to operate on the other flank C3
is on the board
because now the bishop on E2 I mean it
in general it joins the fight with uh
you know B5 and A6 available so I'm not
as concerned about the Rook on E7 at all
now now it's like my solve C3 as a move
I'm feeling good about White's chances
I agree no White's still up a pawn still
has all the positional pluses
I think arjun's overall strategy here is
totally understandable he keeps trying
to spin as much complication as possible
but eventually it's going to fizzle out
he doesn't have an endless supply of
Pawns and pieces that he could just
shove forward
right and queen d8 we've talked about
your move Knight C6 still available
yeah and with the C file opening up
white is in Prime position to put a rook
there eventually uh oh
and not now let's not forget about Rook
C1 now no no no no we're highly
inadvisable
okay F6 the eval bar didn't like
where does the Knight go do you even
move the Knight yeah that's not a given
the other position
exactly
because if it's taken the bishop takes
and well you're actually making serious
threats there you know what could be an
interesting resource is Bishop F3 in
this position
the whole point is that after black
takes and white takes
later on down the line Rook C1 becomes a
massive threat
so that's definitely on the table
something like Bishop F3 or even
yeah I like that Bishop D3
I was even looking at something as
ridiculous as Bishop A6
um but I think it's a little a little
too much apart from ridiculous though
Queen C3 Queen C7 I can tell is your
idea yeah yeah but I can probably
achieve this without the need to give
out the bishop because as you said Rook
C1 is such a strong move like Bishop H5
maybe or something
yeah but moving the bishop is is
critical because Rook C1 fails the
Knight takes E2 check the queen is
overloaded
we think chess bra for the raid
there we go I assume I'm on Hamilton was
not streaming on chess bro yeah no just
on the other monitor here right I was
just over there in Arena Kings you know
two simultaneous streams
okay F6 is on the board a job of
contemplating his next course of action
the plus three eval amount is totally
meaningless here this is anybody's game
yeah four results are possible as you
once said
exactly that's a that's a an important
thing to remember because I think this
Armageddon is going differently than
ones that we've seen in the past this
Armageddon is less about the time I know
white is less time it's a crazy concept
Right started with two and a half
minutes uh extra but I think he's given
up some of his time Advantage because
he's focused on the board
he's saying look I'm gonna like I don't
care about being up on time it's less
about that I'm seeing a position that I
think I can convert just looking at the
the way the game is playing out on the
board and I think he's just decided to
focus on that so I think the the time is
going to be critical that job off
doesn't get too low that he's not able
to play things out properly but uh I I
don't think he's focused on keeping that
time Edge and always staying up no I
think he's looking at the position and
trying to find the kill I think you fit
the nail on the head I think we saw a
lot of players treat the Armageddon game
like it's a hyper bullet game which it's
not it's still a rapid game white still
has 15 minutes yeah there's no increment
you got to be a little bit faster as
you're saying but 724 is an eternity on
the clock for these players who are used
to online Blitz maybe we're a job up a
little bit less so but he's still a
great Blitz player he's not feeling uh
the time crunch just yet so just to
illuminate the idea of Bishop F3 if
black takes on E5 just so we're all on
the same page white plays Bishop takes
C5 let's bring him an analysis board
Rook F7
trade Rook C1 and black is in huge
trouble not because you can't defend the
Knight you can defend it but then you're
gonna end up dropping the pawn on T5 and
Black's position collapses
right like takes tags
and if you take on D5 here
because this is you know it's enough
material when you think about it but
white is probably just gonna sit here
and literally play like H3 and it's like
such a defeating move that next uh Queen
A5 I mean everything is falling black
ironically does not have enough pawns
you need a pawn to Anchor something your
king you know if you had a Pawn on E6 or
Pawn on B6 that would change the
complexion here but no this is gonna be
too much and we might see it Dania on
the board
we have been calling a lot of these
moves this is on the board I think if
her drop off takes in place Rook C1 he
will be knocking on the door
of a huge Armageddon Victory unless
Arjun has some sort of hidden resource
here maybe Knight no Knight B1 doesn't
work either
Knight A4 is on the board we're gonna
see that position
and is such a classy move to play at the
end of the line it's easy so easy to
miss you might be thinking about this
whole line Bishop D5 Knight D5 imagine
you're calculating From arjun's
perspective you see all this you see
Rook takes Queen and then at the end
you're like wait a minute I have a rook
in two pieces for the queen maybe I have
back rank tricks and white just plays H3
and you're like oh okay this is really
annoying now there's no threat to
White's King the queen runs rampant into
position and don't forget white has the
F Pawn the E Pawn the d-pawn three pawns
connected as well yeah it's just winning
the material plays a role but ultimates
it's the lack total lack of King safety
it's the discombobulated nature of
Black's minor pieces that are totally
scattered they can't coordinate and the
fact that white Scott not just three
pawns but three Pawns in the center you
have this idea of playing F3 E4 and D5
Timor needs to cut cut some time here
and just grab that pawn on D5 he needs
to trust his intuition here the one way
that you fail to win this with white is
you get inside your own head you take
too long on the obvious decisions and we
saw what that leads to in game three
yeah couldn't agree more
um he's giving a one last double check
because I I think he feels after Bishop
D5 that Knight takes D5 is so winning
for him so he might even be looking at
like King G6 just making sure he's got
all the bases covered but of course
white just takes in the corner and can
even look to sacrifice
and I think one line you had to double
check after Bishop takes eight is the
move 92 check looks very scary
but white can just recapture on E2 I
won't make these moves because I think
you know let's focus on the game
continuation but at the end of the lion
white covers the back rank check with
Queen F1 and he's just on three pawns
exactly two more just making sure of
that making sure that he's not
blundering any tactics but Bishop F3
probably even better because D5 is
totally Unstoppable what a classy move
yeah that's that's just you know he's
sitting back with his you know five and
a half minutes which is an eternity in a
position like this and saying you know
you don't have a single move check that
Rook on A8 trapped can't move actually
cannot move uh Rook B8 only offers
further material and you know the most
decapitating thing is maybe after Rook
B8 you don't even take it
no it's it's totally debilitating and
Bishop G4 by Arjun an attempt to stir
things up
I think the time is right to take on A8
yeah yeah now he's baited the bishop to
G4 it'll fall victim to the move H3 pure
genius on the board by rajaba but in all
seriousness I think that's the idea
Timur just has to realize that after
Bishop takes eight I'll make the moves
really quickly just to make sure again
we're on the same page 92 Queen takes E2
it does look scary oh Queen C1 there's
like Knight c392 but all of that is is
ghosts right because the Knight is not
on C3 it's on A4 and that one tempo
gives white the time to go on the
offensive and forget that White's up two
puns he's just gonna Checkmate the black
king after something like Bishop e65 all
the bases are covered yeah and I mean it
for me even before Queen C4 check in
this line it's just the move H3 a season
of H3 in every line and I'm like that's
enough that's enough for me to be like
okay we're totally fine no this is this
is if Arjun pulls this off
I will have literally nothing to say for
the rest of the cgc yeah I mean if he
pulls us off I mean what can we say he
certainly deserves to be there because
your job off will have had everything in
front of him all the chances
um one position that could get I mean
even this isn't enough but could get a
little bit weird is you know H3 Bishop
E2 followed by Knight C3 and blacks just
trying to make this strange claim that
I've trapped your own Queen I can't
attack it I can't move any of my pieces
but I've trapped your own Queen inside
your position Timor is obviously nervous
here and when you get anxious and
there's as much on the line as there is
this game it's the same effect as you
watch a horror movie and then every
sound in your house makes you jump it's
the same thing here where you're blowing
up the enemy to like you know insane
proportions every move looks scary every
Fork uh seems like the end so a job of
has to stay calm most important thing
keep time on your clock don't let Arjun
flag you don't forget that there's no
increment because Arjun is going to pull
out all the stops you just know it
mm-hmm what a move Mighty Moore
that's great knight to E2 check and the
King takes the journey to F2 right
you've got so many extra pawns I would
give like two pawns here just to maybe
like trade the Queens because you know
that your winning chances are still so
high but black can't even get two Pawns
nope and black can't even get the
position into some opposite colored
Bishop end game
he's simply getting mated
yeah
yeah if you don't trade Queens here
um I mean that's Checkmate on the board
let's not forget that white is
threatening probably something like a
Checkmate in I don't know four or five
if uh if it was his turn for example 92
check King F2 and strangely enough every
single piece that black has is hanging
the queen everyone on G7 is hanging yeah
the bishop
it's over if 92 King F2 and you trade
Queens
you know that's where the two minor
pieces hanging is what actually causes
the position to be resignable Knight D1
Last Chance by Arjun that's right take
the queen and take on E3 I think he
wants
gotta try that
white has does what have King E2 here I
know I was about to say does white just
have like you know a real calculated
move
King E2 how cruel
and then you go to D3 Bishop F5
block it with one no there's no way
how do you do that because King G3 is
probably enough
oh totally how many of us would just
play King G3 you know rest on your
laurels get the king out of the danger
zone or drop off takes a dip into the
Mariana Trench again
and he's gonna lift to tell the tale
it's unbelievable because in the line
with King G3 G7 is hanging so like just
everything is so good in that line but
that is just a cruel move thingy too he
is going to win this game that's it I
mean Bishop just take G7 D5 literally
even an opposite Clark Bishop end game
is completely winning here
yeah the only way you screw this up is
Again by blundering a fork or yeah
occurrence D5 for example hitting the
Knight Bishop B5 check King F2 you know
Knight D3 I'm closing my eyes
well because King D2 Knight C4 and it's
winning but it's obvious yeah it's
opposite actually I if I'm a hard job
you have to watch for Bishop F1 though
yeah
okay
that's three connected pass bonds and
yeah you have to feel it's sufficient it
must be you just push the pawns that the
Kryptonite for opposite card Bishops is
connected passers because you can use
your king and Bishop to push them
through a defensive barrier
and rajaba who's gonna convert this he's
got plenty of time yeah he's he's got
too much time honestly way too much time
and after he's I think arjun's gonna
resign
one or two more moves Yep this won't
last long because the king or gets to E5
and
um I know we're kind of in the closing
segments here but I will just point out
that although this is absolutely routine
for these guys
the way that he's advancing the pawns is
so crucial you advance the pawns on
light squares and then you put them side
by side and when you advance them again
they go on light squares so you don't
play Pawn in E7 and play Pawn to D7 and
that is enough to take victory in this
Armageddon game Dania and what a
comeback I call it a comeback because
mentally I feel like rajaba came back in
this match to win what should have been
his in the first place chess is a cruel
game there's always going to be someone
who's euphoric and someone who's
devastated but we gotta make a clear
chess is an effort between two games
right it's an artwork that's produced by
two people and Arch and aragaisy played
an integral role in this match being as
exciting as it was the way that he
fought in the second game uh the way
that he fought in the third game and
pulled off a miracle and of course an
on-demand victory in game four it was
only because as you said timuru rajaba
was able to gather himself and survive
some unbelievable tension in the armaged
end game that the match doesn't go his
way what a match we just saw this was an
absolute treat
yeah this this was tremendous what a
victory from rajabov who also you know
credit to Amy he made 14 minutes he was
like honestly give me the white pieces
that's what that bid says he wanted the
white pieces he liked how things were
going in this match uh really really
bold decision to go for that and it paid
off he he honestly has had some really
exciting games with the the white pieces
against Arjun in this match he didn't
necessarily get the full point out of
all of them but Rook B3 Daniel I go back
to that and I'm thinking you know
interesting move interesting prep and
that Rook actually shaped the entire
game Rook B3 Rook B7 you know the Rope
went to E7 I don't know how it stayed
alive but that shaped how this entire
game went it really did I think this was
actually the Turning Point like Arjun
had the opportunity to defend the B7
Pawn he could have played B6 you could
have played B5 and Knight B6 Knight C4 I
think this would have been the most
prudent option instead he decides to
sacrifice p7 it's a Fearless skull it's
a gutsy call we can't criticize him for
that Arjun did everything in his power
to make sure this game went his way but
the Precision with which team will
rajabov handled the stage of the game
Bishop F3 a month is nothing short of
amazing and then a little bit later how
many of us would just take on A8 no
Bishop F3 the patience he had in this
stretch is incredible and the conversion
was clean and impeccable
yeah there's that's just a perfect
summary for jabov a totally deserved
winner but our generic I see almost made
that full comeback you know making her
job of regret uh his his previous game
immensely as we see that final score it
went all the way to Armageddon uh Eric I
see you know down one and a half came
back to draw a dead lost position and
then win on demand in game four to make
for one of the most exciting games
exciting matches in the round of 32 and
it does mean that the more of a job of
Winston Armageddon Daniel moves on to
the round of 16.
yeah he is the last one the lucky one he
rounds off the final group of 16 and he
rounds off the final unfinished bracket
The Groovy bracket is now complete that
means all of the brackets are now
complete
well 16 players will not be going to
Toronto eight players will be going to
Toronto at the start of November and uh
there are going to be some incredibly
fascinating matches that are coming up
but we will tell you about them after
the break first we have an interview
with Mr rajapov the hero of today's
match so don't go anywhere we are going
to ask Timor for his thoughts on his
fascinating match his mental toughness
and first we're gonna set him up so
ladies and gentlemen we hope you enjoyed
the match stay tuned for an interview
with the job up here at the cgc the
chess.com Global Championship we will be
back in just a couple of short minutes
foreign
we are back at the chess.com Global
Championship reviewing the results of
the final unfinished bracket that is now
finished and it is Seymour rajabov who
survives an incredible comeback content
by Arjun aragaisi demonstrating nerves
of Steel and playing a brilliant
Armageddon game to make his way to the
round of 16 where he will challenge none
other than Jan Napoli to determine who
books a ticket to Toronto and the best
news is that we have Timur in the studio
for an interview tomorrow thank you for
joining us after such a long and arduous
match let's start with the Armageddon
What did you tell yourself to calm
yourself down going to the Armageddon
how were you able to stay so focused and
so centered after uh what happened in
games three and four
well honestly I don't think that I've
played a good game the the one that was
their magadon and my beat was like
something like 14 minutes
and I think that was
um pretty close to 15 so I'm an old guy
I need more time and he decided 12 and
12 minutes and 30 seconds is enough
probably to fold as black but then I
think we've got some crazy position out
of the opening and um yeah it was
actually hard after that you know white
game that I didn't win and just to
secure the match yeah it was hard to
come you know like uh emotionally back
to the normal State and
um yeah I couldn't even play properly
the force game I think that I've played
the bad game there it's just really bad
game I mean just uh like all the moves
were bad I think and um yeah in our
Market on I don't know I just saw they
have to fight and I have to find some
moves not to allow any uh direct draws
so that's why I decided for the sharp
line with the city xd5 and Bishop F4 and
was a bit surprised that he didn't go
for the long lines with this 94 G5 stuff
Knight C6 and so on and was quite happy
about it because the position is
playable and then I don't know what was
happening it was completely crazy and I
was super happy when I found out that
Bishop A8 92 stuff works I mean 22 Queen
F1 and so then of course I'm having like
three bones up and uh you know two
Bishops and all that stuff and still I
was quite afraid to know not to win the
game because
um you know I've missed such a chance in
a third game that yeah
but okay that's that's life
yeah I mean it's a it's a really good
summary I also wanted to ask you about
the Armageddon this move Rook B3 was
this like something you had prepared I
mean we don't always see a rook end up
on B3 you were critical maybe about how
you played the game but it honestly
looked like Rook B3 gave you very
Dynamic chances and it's an Armageddon
game you need to win this Rook B3 part
of that uh prep a little bit or
something you looked at
no no no no I just saw that um I can
play Rook C1 Queen A5 Knight D2 and then
go F3 and uh probably I'm having a
slightly better end game
I mean in case he takes some D2
um like he takes only two I take with
the King you know I'm having two Bishops
and the golden game but actually after
Rook C1 I was afraid of Queen B6 so I
tried to find some moves not to allow
any direct uh you know any direct draw
for him so uh yeah Rook B3 just no it's
not the preparation to be honest I don't
even know what the series says there but
uh just uh seemed natural to me to go
Rook between not to allow Queen B6 in
this position and um yeah still after
Queen A5 I'm going Knight D2 I don't
know what what this what this line is uh
in fact but um you know I was quite
surprised that he really sacrificed
everything so fast I mean he could play
probably some more positional way in
this in this position after Rook B3
because the Rook is kind of awkward
there so probably he can even go some
b697 and C5 or something like this but
uh okay I didn't really care because I
just wanted to seek any chances and uh
have any kind of playable position and
anyway I mean the loss and the draw is
the same thing there so I didn't care
much
uh two more Arjun our guys your opponent
today is part of a group of very
impressive players from The Young
Generation of course kukesh I'm just a
tour of do you feel like those players
this new generation has clearly defined
weaknesses and was there a particular
direction that you were trying to take
these games in in order to exploit what
you perceive to be uh arjun's biggest
weaknesses
well I didn't really uh study too many
of their games to be honest all these
youngsters I'm uh more used to studying
you know all this uh candidate guys and
um certainly I mean the like 10 Indian
teams can can win the Olympic or
something like this and you know the
second team was what's like uh bronze
medalists were they were bronze
medalists or silver in the last Olympia
and uh runs
yeah bronze yeah but still I mean they
were leading throughout the tournament
and you know they have so many strong
youngsters you can mention the Prague
who cash all these guys and of course
Erica easy I think they're just uh
playing great chess nowadays and um they
work very hard with the youngsters I
think the Indian
um I don't know Chess Federation is it
or anyone who is responsible for Indian
chess so uh they have a lot of training
sessions and so on I didn't really
um specifically do something for Erica
is in terms of preparation but I saw
that during the match he was kind of
slightly uncomfortable with the way I
was playing I think he didn't expect me
to go this uh G4 line and probably I
could have could take some chances in
the first game as well I think I've just
uh played this Rook G5 stupidly with D5
idea and then I mean he probably did
some mistakes and I settled for a draw
and settled for a draw but um I think in
the second game I just felt that he's
kind of uncomfortable in playing some
kind of simple position
and he really played bad this thing in
the second game and he was white I think
I mean he could just draw it uh I mean
after Queen B65 I think there are many
ways for white to to be fine but then he
found himself into trouble and then I
managed to win the game yeah I didn't do
any special preparation to be honest so
I don't really have any secrets to tell
you how to beat their egasi or any other
Indian youngster but probably to retain
some energy is good so I didn't do much
at all before the match and so try to
relax as much as I can because I thought
it will be anyway uh kind of tense and
it was
yeah indeed a really tense match which
you ended up emerging Victorious we're
gonna bring up uh for everybody here the
bracket which is now the round of 16. uh
you've Advanced uh Timor and your
opponent we mentioned earlier is going
to be Jan de palmishi I mean any
thoughts on Jan as a as a as an opponent
obviously and did you see some of his
matches he's had some pretty exciting
ones like especially against the spitler
last round
um no didn't really follow but I know
Jan for a long time and uh I've seen him
for uh like um around three or four
weeks in June so that was quite enough
and I didn't study more of his games in
the candidates I mean of course
so uh yeah I know the guy I mean he's a
very strong rapid and Blitz player and
of course the classical chess as well
but rapperton bliss I think he's uh
famous for that and uh yeah just very
happy to qualify through this match
today and it took a lot of nerves uh
even though I'm always you know
convincing myself that
um online she should not really care too
much but then once it starts it's
sometimes more tense than the classical
games that you were playing but
certainly of course I know uh Jan quite
well and we had different results in
online games with him so yeah let's see
what happens I'll be happy to play an
interesting match against him of course
we will be watching that match very
closely Timor thank you so much for
joining us for the interview we will let
you take your well-deserved rest good
luck against Yan
thank you so much thank you for having
me thanks
okay hey Iman and then there were 16.
yeah and there was 16. where did the
120th players go where did the 64 go
where did the 32 go
yeah we whittled it down
we finally know the entire bracket
that's the most exciting part as we you
know I have every match up here every
pairing as you can see them there on
your screen rejabov and the top right
hand corner filling out the the last
name in this bracket and we're getting
so close to knowing who the participants
are going to be in Toronto for the
finals and you heard Timur basically
saying that uh you're supposed to not
care about online chess as much but when
you're sitting there and you know
there's 15 000 people watching on all
the platforms and you know that a ticket
to Toronto Canada and a check for two
hundred thousand dollars is on the line
yeah you're feeling a little bit nervous
maybe even more nervous than the final
game at the candidates tournament and
that is a testament to how awesome the
cgc is these players you know no matter
how calm they are on the outside and
their job off is pretty damn calm I mean
they are eating themselves out on the
inside especially uh after a near choke
this was an epic match and you will want
to acquaint yourself ladies and
gentlemen with everybody on that bracket
some incredibly fascinating matches
coming your way starting with this
Sunday October the 2nd we will have two
matches for us lease so against Jeffrey
Zhang and another All-American matchup
of honoronian against Samuel saving them
on you cannot ask for two matches that
are it's not possible to produce two
pairs of more entertaining than that no
these are the these are the four players
and these are the pairings but uh
seriously I I actually have Wesley in in
my mind Wesley from the very start one
of the favorites one of my favorites to
go all the way in this tournament so I
think I'll definitely have my eyes on
that match Jeffrey Zhang is such a
competitor so resilient I mean you're
not you're never gonna see a match with
Jeffrey finish 3040 he always gets
points on the board and Wesley has been
so consistent in the match format talk
about a single game sure but Wesley in a
match format I feel that he always has
the some way that that he comes out on
top so I'll be looking at that match
Wesley is one of my favorites to go the
distance and of course aronian and Sam
sevian you have this uh you know
All-American day for uh the two
match-ups so uh we're whittling down the
the Americans left in the competition
we'll see how many of them make it to
the top eight
and speaking of Americans and speaking
of more epic matches the following day
on Monday the Sunday matches are coming
your way at noon Pacific 3 P.M Eastern
on Monday three hours earlier at 9 A.M
Pacific noon Eastern we will have two
other matches in the round of 16. Hikaru
Nakamura against lanyard Dominguez a
classic matchup throughout the years
they have played so many times across
the board and Blitzen and rapid and they
will face off once again to determine
who heads to Toronto and Fabiano caruana
who has really resurged in the cgc he
has proven that yeah he's had some tough
performances but he is still freaking
Fabiano caruana but Dimitri on Drake and
Iman that match stands out to me because
then draken has been a totally
Unstoppable force in the cgc everywhere
everything he has touched has turned
into gold on the chessboard and his
opponents have turned into dust are you
as excited about that match as I am I
absolutely am if we pay attention to the
last couple slides as well I think uh
you know chess fans will notice that the
United States Olympia team has just
appeared right in the last slide and in
this slide that there's your Olympiad
team some of the best four or five
players in the entire country are still
in this competition and looking to
advance I look at caruana on draken as
the sort of the the match-up that draws
my attention between the two of them
because on draken has had so much
success so much underrated success I
mean he's a 2700 player you know hasn't
broken into that 2780 Echelon of like
top top players in the world but he's
right there and I feel like in this
shorter time control he is in that top
10 player in the world conversation so
Fabiano caruana he's had some shaky
moments uh qualifying thus far in the
competition I look at this match as a
total toss-up but on Drake and Dark
Horse really really dangerous uh in this
format the match format wrap it as well
so I think on draken right here is as a
guy to keep an eye on and on the other
side Daniel we have NACA and Dominguez
you know sort of uh a much different
matchup actually I think NACA comes in
as a certified favorite for sure but he
also has had kind of ups and downs when
it comes to qualifying he's crushed some
matches as we expect Nakamura too but
he's also had some shaky moments and
Dominguez has this style where you know
if you give him an opportunity he will
take it and pounce immediately he's so
good at converting jumping on mistakes
and I feel like Nakamura if he plays one
of one of his you know vintage Nakamura
style matches I think he's got this but
if he slips up anywhere Dominguez will
be right there to surgically take
advantage of whatever he's given there's
eight players so we'll contest matches
on Sunday and Monday and all eight of
them you could make a case for them
winning the cgc you could certainly make
a case for them uh booking their ticket
to Toronto the top eight players will
head to Toronto at the start of November
it's going to be an epic finale we've
got 16 players remaining and by Monday
uh four of them or uh four of them will
be eliminated
oh my lands them on and another matches
in the books we have concluded the round
of 32 and what a way to conclude it was
let me pass the mic to you one last time
before I wrap up uh for your final
thoughts this seemed to be all about
Psychology today and that is why these
matches are so exciting there's so many
different dimensions to them aren't
there
completely agree uh there's a couple
matches happening when we said we had
one match today we meant officially
because you know there was on the board
off the board the psychology the
mentality and of course the momentum the
momentum I feel was dictating this match
it started off with some really
interesting prep from rajabov uh and
then in the second game it was actually
Arjun who said no I'm not taking early
draw let's play this game out I've got
some ideas here and flipped on its head
as rajav completely outplayed him and
honestly that momentum carried into the
third game it looked like he was gonna
walk away with this match so well
calculated so well executed but a final
trick and a reminder not to count anyone
out in this competition literally until
you see the result on the board as Arjun
came back gave us a game for I think the
fans were just you know clamoring with
excitement that we got to see more of
this match and ultimately it came down
to narmageddon dania where I think
rajabov recomposed himself after Arjun
One On Demand in game four and I think
he played a tremendous game I don't
think he gave himself enough credit for
how well he played in the Armageddon he
most certainly did not that was an
excellent summary and a great note for
us to unfortunately wrap up but once
again you do not have to wait long the
next set of matches are coming your way
Sunday at noon Eastern 9 A.M Pacific and
6 p.m central European Standard time but
for now ladies and Gentlemen We wish you
a great rest of your Wednesday we'd like
to thank everybody in the chat chat with
happened tonight uh tonight uh this
afternoon on uh in Central European Time
essentially of course that's what I
meant on YouTube and on Twitch so we'd
like to thank you for supporting your
favorite player and making the cgc a
magical event that it has been thank you
also to our producer Matt for another
excellent broadcast our entire amazing
team at chess.com and thanks to you Oman
is always a pleasure to commentate with
you but now ladies and gentlemen from
thechess.com Global Championship from
the round of 32 which has now concluded
Grandmaster I'm on Hamilton and
Grandmaster Daniel narrative
great rest of your Wednesday we'll see
you soon
[Music]
foreign